hard work will not make you rich I get
driven nuts by the amount of gurus and
influencers and whatever who want to
brag and say no one can outwork me I'm
the best in the world so many people
outwork me I still make more money than
them there has to be something else one
of the things that grinds my gears about
a lot of the people that I see on
Instagram that you probably see too is
this whole like no one can outwork me
Mantra first off it's objectively false
because many people a outwork you today
be outwork you have in the past see you
haven't met everyone indeed it doesn't
matter anyways it's the same
thing when someone's like I'm the best
and you have to say you're the best
because if you don't think you're the
best it shows that you're not confident
to me I don't take that at all if
someone's like I'm the best then why
aren't you on billboards that's what the
best would look like absolutely you need
to do the work you need to put volume in
it's the only way you get better but if
you start claiming that you are the best
you cannot be outworked you are making
statements that you know are not true
why are we bragging about work because
work has very little to do with the
highest levels of the game Warren
Buffett talks about if he makes two good
decisions a year he's had a good year
and so how is it that one of the best
investors one of the best business
people in terms of measuring it by money
which is how you measure business talks
about how he does basically nothing
reads five or six hours a day eats
McDonald's and makes a couple good
decisions a year how is it that that guy
is making so much more money than the
people who are bragging about the fact
that they work so hard need motivation
watch your top 10 with believe Nation
Hey Kevin Carmichael and I make these
videos because in my first business I
was making 300 bucks a month I quit on
my business partner and the thing that
saved me was studying the stories of
super successful entrepreneurs so I hope
that this story today helps give you the
motivation you need because I still
needed to myself so today let's learn
from one of the best Alex or MOSI and my
take on his top 10 was a success Joy
everyone only has the same hours of the
day anybody who only sleeps eight hours
or only sleeps seven hours and works the
remaining of hours of the day all of
them would be tied for hardest working
so what creates output you have volume
of activity and then you have the
leverage of the activity that you're
doing that's what creates the total
output in order to do anything you must
do something there has to be some level
of energy that gets input into the
system our activity in terms of number
of activities is a very newbie measure
of success in the beginning Warren
Buffett doesn't say I said a thousand
emails today it doesn't talk like that
he's playing a different game Jeff Bezos
didn't like woke up at 4am today now
mind you I'm saying this to somebody who
likes waking up early we can't be as
superstitious about what matters waking
up early doesn't matter go to bed late
doesn't matter not sleeping a lot
doesn't matter the few things that
matter are the inputs that go into the
system that have the most leverage to
create the most output now if you're a
newbie and you can't get your ass off
the couch and by all means figure out
how to actually get your ass off the
couch and do stuff but then there's only
so many hours and so boom and and then
very quickly you hit your capacity of
work great you've maximized that now
what the leverage that we have on that
activity is going to dictate how much we
get out of it and if we do a low
leverage activity many many many times
we might get more than a high leverage
activity that gets done once a CEO who's
going to work with acquisition.com Works
virtually every hour of every day when
they come in almost everybody does
sometimes they ask they're like am I
going to be working more or like it's
impossible for you to work more but you
are going to be changing what you work
on because that's the only lever we have
there's only 24 hours so we're going to
switch these nine out and we're going to
pop these in with higher leverage
activities and so the way that we do
that is we look at their calendars and
we look at their org chart this is how
you grow business you look at what they
spend their time on and you see which of
these activities are low Leverage is
there anyone else in this org chart that
we can hand these activities to and if a
large percentage of these activities are
a certain type of thing and they don't
exist in the orchard then it's a role
that we need to hire the point of why I
hate the concept of no one cannot work
me is that there are many ways to win
the game if you were to think about an
amazing goal as a dragon to be slain if
you are familiar with video games in any
way when you create like a war party you
have a group of people that are going to
go go on a quest you don't just have 10
paladins or guys who just have Shields
and swords so you've got a Healer a mage
that's really good at damage but can't
take a lot of damage then you've got a
paladin who can't hit as hard but he can
take a lot of shots you find people who
have complementary skills if you're
playing football you don't have 10
running backs the entrepreneur really
should be the coach of the team it's
about organizing the pieces and how the
well they play together that ultimately
determines how good the team is like how
many times have you seen the team with
the All-Star that has the poor
Supporting Cast get beat by the overall
better team it happens all the time a
lot of entrepreneurs as I see them are
trying to play the game like they're the
star player and they want to score all
the points but they lose to Apple
because Apple's got a team we celebrate
a specific action like work when it's
really just saying oh look there's a
paladin who can take a lot of hits cool
that's not the only thing that's
required to win I think what is more
valuable is to know what are each of the
roles that exist within the business a b
is there one of these that you map to
based on your characteristics and skill
sets and then see what is my eventual
Evolution through entrepreneurship we'll
start at the beginning which is what are
the players on the field so if you think
about it by function you've got somebody
who has to promote who's got to be a
good marketer they have to understand
how to make things known across
different platforms telling stories
building a brand providing value to an
audience that's what marketing is sales
is being able to convert that raw
attention into a sale direct response
ads sales Pages video sales letters Etc
which is pretty much anything that's
physical products or software based
that's low ticket or it's higher ticket
People to People hand-in-hand combat who
know how to end the beginning sell and
then later train how to sell and then
later later lead people who train how to
sell these are not necessarily the same
people I've met really brilliant
marketers with suck at sales I'm really
good sales people sucking marketing then
you've got somebody who understands
product how do I make something
beautiful the guy who started Shopify
he's not CEO of Shopify he's had a
product he's a mage he knows how to cast
sound else and you've got the
experienced people who are managing
everything outside of the actual product
itself how do customers engage with us
how it can provide more value how give
an amazing experience how do we make
sure they're hitting these Milestones
this person who knows customers
experience and customer success is not
the same person who understands product
and ux and design that's a different
game which is different the guy who
knows how to close this different guy
that knows how to promote the bigger the
Enterprise gets the more specialized the
skill becomes and the deeper The Well of
experience that people need to be they
have to be more specialized when people
are like I can't be outworked you're
bragging about the wrong thing it should
be like I can't be out recruited I can't
be outmanaged no one can build a culture
like me that's super high leverage
across your organization no one can lead
like me but no one can outwork me it's
just an irrelevant activity metric I
love working I work all the time but I
would never claim that no one works
harder than me I tend to have very good
leverage with the activities that I do I
spend tons of time writing a book in
that book prints and sells copies
forever it's a different way to play the
game and so level two of this which
player you are in the Middle Run of this
you end up segregating your off to a
portion of the business that you're an
expert at or that you're best at CMO or
chief sales officer Chief product
officer it's not about one player being
the champion here it's about how the
team works together which then gets to
the third level of this is just about
being the coach think about the best
coaches do they're literally trying to
head hunt the best players and they're
trying to recruit the best people from
college look at what Google does think
about their recruiting efforts they have
huge influxes dedicated to getting the
best and smartest people out of college
and they have another ring for the best
and smartest people come out of business
school and then another one is their
very high level recruiting at the top of
the executive level the parallels
between sports and business they are
almost the same in that way now mind you
you can only have you know 10 or 11
people on the field you might have ten
thousand but if each of those players
represents a function or Department of
the business it makes more sense when we
move up the levels of Entrepreneurship
we need to make sure that we're playing
the right game and that we're using the
right metric to measure our success
final level of this is being the coach
is recruiting the top level Executives
and creating a farm system underneath to
feed into to the company that you have
so you can have a sustained competitive
advantage and create a dynasty for the
team so you can create the best winning
team every year and have the soft skills
of creating culture of high performance
so that you get the most out of every
individual player and the difference
between amazing coaching and mediocre or
poor coaching is what would players do
if they had no coach or leader and then
what would they do if they had the best
coach and best leader the Delta between
those two is the value of the coach the
value of the CEO the CEO needs to have
the highest return on time out of anyone
in the organization because they need to
always be solving the next problem as
long as when they replace their time the
activities they do with the new stuff
builds the business even more then that
trade will always work and if CEO can
come in and turn a business around even
behemoths around in two three years
based on the standard they set and the
values that they stand for that Delta
across the entire organization is your
greatest leverage rule number two is
choose friends carefully I have shed
friends every season of my life my
closer Circle has always been very very
small very very small
very very small
very small
um non-existent um I also feel like I
grow really quickly because I don't hold
on to things long the moment something
doesn't provide me value I shed it I
think about my life in three to five
year Seasons first I was a high school
womanizer for the most part and then I
was also like really deeply angry I had
high school friends that when I left
high school I'd basically stopped being
in contact with them and then I had my
come to Jesus where my dad was like you
suck as human you have a terrible
reputation maybe you should stop being
who you are cleaned up my ACT I stopped
drinking nearly as much as I was I
started going to school and studying 12
hours a day present the fraternity and
that was my college season and I had
College friends and then when I left
College I pretty much stopped being in
contact with anyone that I went to
college with most people suck at most
things and aren't Bound for greatness
because of who they are and the choices
they're willing to make the stories
about friends leaving the hometown and
no longer remember where they're from is
one that is told by Society because
Society is the majority the majority of
people get left behind if you look at
the things that you want to to get in
life there's a price for them you don't
buy everything you see in the mall why
not because you don't want to pay the
price just because you might think that
a shirt or jacket is cool just because
you think an outcome is awesome you
might not be willing to make the trade
winners and losers have the same goals
the goal doesn't make you unique it's
the willingness to pay the price that
makes you unique it's like everyone
wants to be rich one of the reasons that
I cut people out sooner than most is
because I do not like the labels they
speak over me one of the big things with
identity is the labels that we say about
ourselves I am ex I am impatient I am
angry I am whatever right I am poor I
don't like saying it people in your past
have the identity that they know you as
and then they will speak and they will
beat that label into you because you're
not matching their pattern why have you
changed you are X you are why and you're
trying to not be that because you're
doing something different than changing
you're growing but they see it as change
and that's why the best response in the
world to someone who says hey you've
changed is to say yeah you have it the
amount you like or love someone is
directly proportional what you're
willing to give up to maintain their
relationship for example if there's a
piece of your car right you work on it
all the time you might say that guy must
really love it because of how much time
he puts into that thing this guy must
really love his country because he's
willing to give his life for it what are
you willing to give in exchange to
maintain the relationship if you're not
willing to give up basically anything to
maintain their relationship
then how much do you love them I think
it's been a very helpful filter for me
to say not do I love my friends but
which friends do I love the most which
friends am I willing to sacrifice the
most to keep the relationship and I am a
big believer in utility there is an
exchange in every relationship you get
something and they get something back
people don't like the idea that
relationships are transactional
but they are transactional just has a
commercial vibe to it but if we just
think about it as from a behavior
standpoint you've got two things that
can happen a behavior is reinforced or
it is punished that's it when you have
exchanges quite literally with people
those exchanges are either reinforced or
they're punished part of the strength of
the relationship is how long you're
willing to wait for the next time that
relationship is reinforced if you have a
long history of positive experiences
with a person you're willing to wait a
longer period of time if they're going
through a breakup they're having a hard
time to keep the relationship going but
at some point even if you've been
friends with somebody for 10 years if
there's just not any positive
reinforcement at some point
you do cut it off the people who are
surrounded with when we grow up it's
very unlikely just from a population
standpoint that they're going to be
great statistically that they're going
to be the top one percent or point one
percent is unlikely so it would make
sense that you change your friends over
time why do people get so weird about
keeping relationships that don't serve
them I think it's just because we have a
societal story around it that you're a
bad friend but I could also think of me
being as a good friend to my next friend
that I just made room for there's gonna
be a friend who's going to move in to my
spot on my buddy's calendar who does
want to do fantasy football who does
want to drink with him on Sunday so it's
not this like all right I'll go to the
game with you but I'm not drinking oh
dude you're not gonna come on man
because the other guy's like yeah shots
all around and they're gonna have a
blast they would better be served with
people who want the same things as them
just because I'm not seeing them anymore
doesn't mean that I don't wish them well
but if someone only tells you the
stories when you got up and while
you did that stupid thing they're
encouraging you in retelling in the
story of who you used to be and you want
people around you who don't believe the
lies you used to tell about yourself the
character trait shift is not a binary
it's how patient are you how kind are
you how loyal are you how honest are you
and so you want people who encourage you
in the behaviors that you want to be
like and this is why I like shedding
identities is such a core part of
Entrepreneurship is that you have to be
willing to say I am no longer this way I
will no longer behave in this way and I
don't accept that reality as truth many
of the people I had around me hey
weren't willing to pay the price that I
was willing to pay for the things that I
wanted but also wanted me to give them
more than I was willing to and so I'll
give you a story that will paint me in a
bad light and that's fine there was a
teacher that I grew up with in high
school and he's the one who stayed with
me after school for a year and worked
out with me two hours a day and you
taught me how to work out I got in shape
got more confidence better at school
from there that snowballed into me
getting into fitness huge Catalyst
snowball somebody heard that story and
then found the teacher and they linked
us he was like hey man I'm not asking
for a lot I would love to just have like
a two-hour quality every week
I was like two hour call every week
I was like I don't even talk to my
mother that much I don't talk to anyone
that much I talk to my wife that's it
the value of the relationship was in the
past you may be like Alex you're a
horrible person and that's possible
maybe I am I was not willing to give two
hours a week 100 hours a year for the
rest of my life
to pay a debt for somebody who worked
out with me because we only have so much
Juju we only have so much time we have
so much Focus so much energy that we can
pour into things and if you're not
putting all your energy in One Direction
it's scattered and then you don't move
as fast my closest friend I spent one
hour a week with every week my closest
friend like clockwork it's my highest
party meeting it is something that
brings me joy and we get lots of
exchange with one another he's the one
who helped him write my book Dr Kashi Dr
Kashi here I get a lot from that now if
I didn't get anything from that over
time slow down the communication between
us I would make it every other week once
a month if you slow down your
communication cages with someone how
frequently you see them and when you
accept invitations it naturally Fizzles
but if it gets to a point where if
someone's like so close that it would be
obvious and a conversation needs to be
had I encourage you to just have it you
want to be a kind person and the way you
are kind is that you tell the truth and
you just be honest and the easiest way
that I can tell you to be honest is you
know when you talk about somebody behind
their back just say it to them it's like
yeah Sandra's been like all over the
place lately and she's like I don't know
drinking a little bit too much Sandra
you've been all over the place lately
you've been drinking a little bit too
much I'm just not sure if I want to
associate with that right now people
just don't have the balls to do that but
if you do that I promise you you either
have better relationships or you'll be
done with this Mickey Mouse of
not even being in a real relationship
and not wanting to confront reality
because you may have a shot at getting
them to realize that they're not on the
path that they wanted to be on because
you were friends with him at some point
and so either your goals have changed or
theirs have if you listen to Kobe's
interviews where he talks about his
friends he says very explicitly that
he's willing to put everything on the
Altar for his dream now some people may
make the argument that's not quote
healthy the question that we're
answering here is not how do we do
healthy stuff question is how do we
become the greatest people will judge
you on how you spend time and their
judgments are simply Expressions that
they would not spend their time the same
way you do hey you work a lot and I
could say hey you don't to the same
degree it's like you spend so much time
with your kids
right if I say it like that people like
wait no I'm supposed to it's only the
supposed to this the thing that gives
all the emotional charge to these
conversations otherwise it's just
observing reality you can't expect to do
the same thing everyone else is doing
and somehow achieve a different outcome
once you have the vacuum of friends
because you'll probably have weeded
people out then the best thing to do is
join communities and then you'll make
friends with people in those communities
who have the same goals as you and then
if you crush it because you understand
that volume is the answer and time is
the ingredient you're going to rise in
that community and you'll gain more
status and you'll start hanging out with
people who are at the top of that
community and then you can LeapFrog into
other communities it's just lunch tables
on steroids I've wanted to live a rare
life and so I will have to be surrounded
by Rare people and rare people are by
definition rare they are not common My
Hope Is that the people that I meet now
are trying to go all the way with me I
want to do epic if I die and don't do
epic I will be bummed how much am I
willing to endure or sacrifice in order
to maintain that relationship that I
have with my dream if I have many many
friends over different seasons I'm
totally cool with that thank you for
that season it was awesome I I don't
believe things need to be forever to be
good and it's only the romantic story
that we were told of friends for life
Etc if you die with one good friend or
two good friends like you've had a
really good life rule number three is
find the right Mentor I've had a lot of
mentors in my career many of them were
paid a few of them were free the point
of a good teacher is that the student
does pass the teacher I see this thing
that happens all the time when you are a
kid and you learn arithmetic first you
learn your numbers and then you learn
how to add you level up and you learn
how to multiply and then you level up
from there and you learn algebra when
you get to algebra you don't think man
my arithmetic teacher is a idiot I can't
believe they didn't teach me this stuff
it's like dude you weren't ready and you
had to have the arithmetic in order to
get to the multiplication it's not that
that teacher was an idiot it's that that
was the sequence and so when you have a
first teacher that teaches you the
basics and you have a more advanced
teacher later it doesn't mean you should
sit on your first teacher it's like that
person got you ready to receive the next
thing earlier on my career I definitely
did the other way this guy didn't know
anything this guy's the guy rather than
seeing it like you would see any other
thing that you'd have in school I've had
the opportunity and the and you know the
gift of being able to Mentor whatever
you want to say you know provide advice
counsel share my experiences a lot of
people hold me in in a regard and most
people who are winners are competitive
it's just like who you are right you
want to win you want to beat everybody
because that's that's part of the
competitive drive but I think there's
like a there's a comma there that needs
to get put in which is that you have to
accept two things one is that you are
going to die and no one is going to
remember like real real ten thousand
years from now no one's going to
remember at all number two is that when
you're at the end of your life the
people who are going to be your buyer
bedside are not the people who you
Vanquish but the people that you helped
I know that I have passed a lot of the
mentors that I've had in my career in
terms of financials Etc earlier on used
to think that made me better than them
as I've had a couple more years and some
more more scars I've realized something
different which is that I was only able
to get better than them because they
gave me the Head Start step on my
shoulder you can reach that next Branch
I think I experience a lot of Joy
knowing that other people don't have to
suffer as much you know we're walking
around outside yesterday someone's like
dude I did everything you have and we're
doing four million dollars a year now
like he was like emotional just knowing
that it's happening it makes stomaching
the hard times easier it feels like it's
not just me trying to do this for myself
it's me trying to do this for a lot of
people if I'm failing over and over
again at this thing I know that once I
figured out I'll be able to help 100
people cheat code their way through it
and not spend five months figuring
something out or two years figuring
something out like I was stuck at Mid 30
million for three years to everyone
watching they're like boohoo that's not
the point is that there's another guy
who's going to get to that point and
he's going to move right past it like in
a blink of an eye because I've had the
right advice that I didn't have and I
think that if the mentees and the
mentors both see it that way then the
mentees will stop on the mentors that
help them and the mentors will stop
trying to hold back secrets that have
propelled them further because the point
is not that you're going to beat
everyone you're going to get really old
and then you're gonna die as you're
getting older they're going to be people
who are younger who had a head start and
as long as the next guy honors the fact
that that guy died on the battlefield to
give him these lessons and come back and
they have to recognize that they're
going to die on the battlefield too for
the Next Generation to pass them they
have it easier than us
that's the point of progress and so
rather than lamenting that the Next
Generation has it easier I thought that
what we all say I want to make the world
a better place well that's what making
the world a better place looks like we
say that this is our mission with our
business we want to make the world a
better place we want to make an impact
and then when it actually happens we
resent the kids for the fact that they
didn't have it as hard as us that was
the point my point is not to beat the
progeny my point is to forge as far as I
can look back and be like hey watch out
for that whole watch out for that rock
keep going keep going they move through
the path that we tread three times
faster than we did because we already
cleared all the trees they get to the
next non-clearing and they have to start
hacking away and hacking away and
hacking away to force the next PATH and
then they become the mentors turn around
and the Next Generation moves six times
as fast to cover my distance and their
distance if you look at some of the
greatest success stories a lot of them
talk about their mentors Warren Buffett
had his mentor early on the quick story
on that was that he said I'll work for
you for free and Paul Graham told him
you're overpriced he was the one that
was going to be giving far more to this
relationship even if Warren gave him his
time he still was going to to be on the
losing side but he still did it anyways
because he recognized that Warren had a
gift Warren passed him in his career
you'll notice that Warren isn't like man
I'm so much better than Paul Graham I
passed that dude in my like 40s he
doesn't talk like that we really do
stand on the shoulders of the Giants
when I think about like the gratitude
that I have for the Gary Vee's who was
12 years older than I am he's forged so
much of this path that like I didn't
have to think about how am I going to
create this whole thing it's like he
already had a blueprint I could just
start laying that out immediately
execute there are guys who we have in
our portfolio right now who are in their
20s who are making twice when I was
making at 30 but if they came to me
below and then now they're above that
was the point garyvee didn't have Gary
Vee to Mentor him on his career I do
right now we all do many of us will pass
Gary and I don't think Gary months
there's a 20 year old it might be you
who's watching this and you've got me
that's the point I'm still going to be
hustling trying to beat you don't get me
wrong when I see guys who are in their
60s I'm like man by the time I'm 60. I'm
gonna be 10 times as wealthy as that 10
times the the real estate 10 times yeah
but if they had had themselves as
mentors they would too if your mentees
and the students that you have and the
people that you help and the people that
you teach don't move above you it means
that you're a bad teacher not a good one
the new definition of success of a
teacher is that the students surpass the
teacher and then get to the point where
they're both looking together with his
experience and his Raw Talent looking at
the new landscape saying all right what
do you think we should do rule number
four is invest your time wisely I think
um like people have two sets of
resources right that they allocate that
they've got time they've got money yeah
and so if you look at someone's bank
statement and you look at their calendar
you know what their life is and you can
also predict whether life is going to be
in x amount of years right and so if
someone wants to change what their life
is going to look like you have to
reallocate where you're investing the
resources that you have and so from a
Time perspective people who are poor in
my opinion spend a lot of time not doing
stuff and that sounds terrible to say
but like at the base level they're
distracted they're not doing the right
stuff right what was I would even say
not doing anything just distracting them
right playing video games Netflix Etc
you know all that stuff right so they've
got there's like the basis like they
don't do anything they're purely
distracting themselves from their
current state which is hard because it's
hard to confront reality if you're like
not happy it's easier to just distract
yourself right now the level above that
is you've got people who are operating
they are working every day but they're
operating in low leverage opportunities
right so they're they're doing things
that do not give them a lot of return on
their time right and so it's like I
could work it doesn't matter how many
hours I work at McDonald's I like it's
very very difficult to come wealthy
there right just near impossible right
um versus like you could
buy a building for 10 million dollars
and then sell to somebody else for 11
you know for 11 million dollars just get
the contract and make a million dollars
on the exchange
super high leverage right from a Time
perspective which is crazy for somebody
who doesn't have money to even
contemplate something like that but the
only way that that happened and that
required no money is skill right and so
like that's an example of like it didn't
require money to make that money that's
skill that's required to do that and so
first is the time right people are not
doing stuff with the time that they have
or they're doing low leverage activities
with the time they have and then they're
not trying to increase their output per
unit time which means investing in their
skill set so like one of the easiest
ways to gain leverage on your time in
and when I say leverage just for
everybody like Leverage is the
difference between inputs and outputs in
a system so
um you know archimedia said if you give
me a lever long enough I can move the
world and so the same degree if you have
enough skills you can do anything right
and so skills give you leverage on your
time so you get more out of each unit of
time so if I'm a master cold caller I
will get more sales and calls booked for
the same unit of time that somebody who
sucks at it same time more output right
because they developed a skill at a
masterful level 100 yeah and so when
people are allocating their time
um they're not by percentage they're
they're kind of like consuming their
time rather than investing their time so
they're either doing nothing
or they're consuming the time rather
than putting time into getting higher
Returns on their time which is education
right and so education you can have from
like the conceptual learnings watching
stuff like this
um or and or the actual doing right and
so you know you learn in action 100
failing messing up you know feeling like
an embarrassment and reactions yeah the
first thousand uh cold calls you make
the first thousand cold emails you do
the first thousand doors you knock on
the first thousand you know what like
you'll learn more from that than you'll
learn from every single book you read up
to that point on the concept like you'll
learn right
um and so people don't allocate nearly
enough time to that in the beginning
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all of the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is find your
happiness deficits occur when we speak
desires right and so I love this
statement
um a desire is a contract we make with
ourselves to be unhappy until we get
what we want and so whenever we State a
desire like I want this I want this
amount of money I want whatever you
literally sign a contract that says like
I won't be unhappy until that happens
right and so like I had this thing
earlier on where I was like I want to
have meaning I want to have great
meaning in my life and I was talking to
a guy who made a lot more money than me
because I asked him I said how do you
create and Destroy meeting in your work
that was the question I asked him on a
podcast and he was like why do you think
life needs to be meaningful and it was
the same exact thing as the happiness
versus like the meaning thing where it's
like I say life has to be meaningful and
therefore everything that I'm doing like
I create expectation of Life whereas if
life just is it just is and it's the
only way that you can actually be there
it's just it's just pure acceptance
right
um which is why like the whole like
shoulds of like we should work we should
have balance we should X it's like I
believe marriage is a compromise like
these are just statements of belief that
are casting expectations out in the
world that are just bound to be untrue
at some point and then create dissonance
and so it's like I believe marriage is
marriage and I believe my marriage is my
marriage and I believe your marriage is
your marriage and like I believe that I
can work 24 hours a day if I want to and
that is all period not and it's bad or
and it's good there's no judgment on it
it just is and so like if I get you know
if I get dopamine secreted in my brain
when I start working cool like and I
will optimize for dopamine and if I die
I know that in a thousand Generations
nothing I do anyways is going to matter
so who cares like that's like the the
opening thing in my book is like there
are no rules like we live in this like
this like shoulds and have to's and like
like like happiness everyone talks about
it and it's just like everyone is
unhappy because they say they want to be
happy rather than being like accepting
like happiness like I just am period and
then like I don't need to judge the am
it just is rule number six is learn how
to earn as a quick you know Pro tip for
everybody if you've got stuff that
people ask you to do for them because
you're good at it maybe you're good at
Tech it's like can you help me set up my
like Wi-Fi and stuff you know blah blah
it's like that means you're solving
problems you can chart like what people
ask you to do as a favor is an
indication of the things that you can
charge for later right so
I had all these people who are asking me
uh not all these I mean a handful of
people who had asked me for programs and
stuff and so what I did was during my
last year of Consulting I started
something called the free training
project and so the free training project
was I would charge 500 to a thousand
dollars but I would I wouldn't charge it
they had to donate that to the charity
their choice in exchange to work with me
right and so that way I wanted people to
Value it but they weren't paying me
directly so they'd get a write-off they
felt good I had a ton of Goodwill also
in the marketplace too because I was
like I'm doing all this stuff for
charity I got I got all these people
reaching out to me like this is so cool
right and so after a year of doing that
I had probably I don't know 12 really
good test of like great before and after
pictures that I had collected from my
clients and I told them that was part of
the deal I was like I'll like you have
to donate it I would like to do this for
real later but
um you have to let me use your
testimonial they were like that's fine
so once I had that
um I had those first you know 10 12
customers who had who had great before
and after pictures
um I transitioned many of those
customers said hey I'm doing I'm going
to do this full time now are you
comfortable paying the same amount
you're paying to charity except just
making a charity of Alex because Alex
can't eat either and so and that was
actually how I transitioned from not for
profit or donating everything and I'd
even set up the entity I just told them
to literally donate it and send me the
screenshot I didn't even do anything
like that um and so I didn't have a
website all I had was an LLC and a
PayPal account so like for everybody's
like I don't know how to start a
business I was like you literally just
need a bank account and a way to process
money that is it like two things and you
can Google how to figure out if you
can't figure it out from Google
entrepreneurship might not be for you
all right but you let like think about
there's 30 million businesses in the
United States 30 million other people
have figured this out
which means you can too so bank account
payment processing make the first 10
free or some sort of charitable thing so
that people like don't feel weird or you
don't feel weird about selling Etc after
you have it after you're providing this
service to people you can transition
people from free service to paid service
and if they don't want to start paying
you then that gives you insight as to
either you suck right or they suck which
is also possible too but either way
a certain percentage of those people
will continue to stay and pay you now
you have income now you can also ask
those people for referrals which is
exactly what I did so I think half that
business came in just from I got you
know the initial ones came in from
friends and family and me posting and so
I was I'll I'll close the loop on what I
said earlier a year later after I had
the testimonials I made a public post
being like hey I've got this thing now I
made a website which is that was my big
announcement I made a website I still
have the post I found it it's 2013. uh I
was like I made I made a website and uh
I I am now open for business and so if
you would like you know training stuff
let me know
um this is what I'm doing now you know I
had some testimonials and go check out
the site whatever and so from there I
was able to get I think about 20 guys uh
who were willing to let me do just like
almost bodybuilding type stuff because I
was kind of like what I was powerless
back then and so
um I think I want to say I got 20 guys
at 200 bucks a month and so I was making
four thousand dollars a month
uh from those people and it took me four
hours every Saturday to do the
Fulfillment what was the Fulfillment
just I would just update their training
programs and and send them nutrition uh
like update their macros
s updated meal plans
um and then like you know new workouts
split for the week Etc
um and then I and everyone had my cell
phone and I would just text them the new
stuff and if they had any questions they
could hit me up like it was a very
simple business
um and so that's what I did it was just
one-on-one online and it only took me
four hours on Saturday morning and to
show you what kind of person I am I
hated it uh even though I loved Fitness
I hated having to do something the same
thing every day
um like on the delivery side so I ended
up having the genius idea of saying oh I
need to own a gym because then I'll be a
business owner I'm really just
self-employed right now
um and so that's what got me to start my
gym rather than probably doing the wiser
decision saying okay this case cost you
four hours a week and you're making four
grand a month maybe you should do this
for 40 hours a week rule number seven is
reframe your thinking if you think about
us as kids right like how do you how do
you Orient yourself of the world you get
reinforced or punished at all at all
phases directly indirectly but you get
reinforced or punished and the things
that you get reinforced you do more of
the things you get punished you last up
right like that's just how how we how we
learn Behavior how we learn to function
in society Right Touch the thing ah it
hurts it's that's we got punished okay
you know you uh your parent tells you to
sit down and be quiet and eat
and you learn to sit down and shut up
and eat and then we wonder why adults
don't move because we're told to sit
when we're running around right we learn
at school sit down and be quiet and we
wonder why uh we eat so much when the
reward for everything we did when we
were a kid was food right we wonder
these things so the reason external
validation is so hard at least for me is
because it's how I learned everything is
because external validation gave you
know gave me the the directional
guidance of what's good and what's not
and then as you get older it's where am
I going to get that validation from and
so I would say that my external
validation
um comes is still 100 there it just
comes from different sources so I'm more
selective on Whose validation I want so
how much external validation do you need
in order to
overcome this belief to go all in and do
it in half the time no I think I just I
need to be able to validate myself and
that's fundamentally I think having
Titus said this he said like if you need
someone else's
if you need here's this quote it's so
good but it's basically like
you need to be able to give you don't
need to swear to somebody else you
should be able to swell your swear to
yourself and bear witness to yourself
because your word should be good enough
so you need to eliminate external
validation right from you feeling good
enough probably yeah it's probably that
like obviously you need it's good to
have feedback in life so I think that's
why it's it's also difficult for some in
general because it's not eliminate or
have more of it's to what degree and
from whom and about what and so then it
gets a little bit more complex but even
using those different lenses I think
it's it's good to unpack it for anyone
who's listening which is like okay
Layla said this so this is not mine
um but most times when we're afraid of
something
it's not actually like this amorphous
crowd that we're afraid of it's like one
or two people's in that opinion like
it's your dad or it's your whatever it
is right and you're worried about what
they're gonna think and they're not even
thinking about you but you think they're
thinking about it they're thinking about
their dad
whatever it is right and so she restated
this earlier on to Mike like when we
were together five years ago she was
like are you and she like made me name
the person it wasn't my dad it was
somebody else for this particular thing
she's like are you gonna let this guy
stop us from getting what we want wow
and it was like when I saw it it was
like looking in front of me I was like
she's like what if this guy hates you
and thinks you're terrible is that a
worthy enough reason to still keep going
and I was like yeah she's like let's go
you know what I mean and so she's very
good with that rule number eight is
focus on one thing it's first you
develop the skills right at a proficient
level then you dive deep on those skills
so that you get better and better at
them and typically that comes through
consistent execution and repetition
which means that it takes the character
traits of focus and determination and
drive right and being able to be
consistent and not go like go away and
start looking at shiny objects looking
at shiny objects looking at a new
opportunity looking at this other side
hustle you want to do whatever it is
right because there's always new things
and what's crazy about this is that the
higher up you go the more seductive the
woman in the red dress looks like and
I'm saying that from a matrix is my
all-time favorite movie
um the woman in the red dress
I'm using this as a as a parable or
whatever a visual for opportunity and
when you're starting out the woman in
the red dress always looks attractive
and the thing is is that the higher up
you go the more of a 10 she becomes now
if you're a girl than I don't know a guy
in a red suit I don't know maybe that
looks more like a pimp so forget about
that but whatever you know George
Clooney or whoever your person is
whatever you're my point is
um like I thought that I was having
discipline and saying no to a certain
level of opportunity when I was starting
my gyms right and I had to develop that
discipline and then we started and then
we started making a few million dollars
a year and I was like okay I need to
develop a new level this one because
there's more things that I want to do
that I have to not be able to do right
one of the biggest successful things I
did was not start the cell phone company
until a year and a half after almost two
years after gym one started all right I
had planned starting the supplement
company at the same time as I started
gym launch original
three and a half four years ago like
they were at the same time I wanted to
do both and Layla the angel that she is
was like no that's stupid don't do that
and so she thankfully was like
you have to have you have to stay
focused and so because of that we were
able to have the explosive growth that
we did and then at the right time we
were able to bolt that on now
um big big big big big picture I don't
know if I would have done it again I
still probably would have stayed even
more focused on gym launch if I could do
it all over again now we have it you
know we we write a check for 600 000
every single month to our gym Lords uh
in terms of commission checks so that's
real money that I get to send back to
the community and that's very fulfilling
for fulfilling for me
um and it solved a problem that I always
had when I have my gym so like there are
reasons that I did it
um and uh and so
like history will tell whether it was
the right call or not um I can never
live the life of what it would have been
if I hadn't done it
um but I think if I were going back in
time knowing what I'd known out I might
not have done it
um but you never know so I'm telling you
like I've I've made these mistakes you
know what I mean and the thing is is
that that level of opportunity looked
even more seducting or seducing or
whatever the word is
um when we had two years more of a
distribution base compared to when we
had at the beginning and so I wasn't
able to say no to her that opportunity
later on as I was in the beginning and
that was a deficiency in my skill set at
the time my character trait of staying
focused right and so
um like I'm saying all this if you're
looking at it in terms of in in
verticals the first step is filling the
holes and that's stacking all the skills
together so you can get the first dollar
to go over and that's just becoming
proficient not amazing just proficient
you don't have to be an expert at
running traffic you just need to be able
to actually know how to run an ad and
the thing is is that most proficient
skills only take like like not a lot of
time like you can Google how to do X and
if you consume for like two hours of
information you'll probably be
proficient most people just don't take
those two hours to do it because that's
uncomfortable and you're not good at it
right
so you consume the information and then
you try right and then you fail because
you're not good at it you learn and then
just use those first initial tries you
learn more in your first 20 sales than
you do in the first 20 hours of learning
about sales stuff right your first time
you actually step in the ring you learn
more about fighting than you do during
all the time that you're practicing
right because it's real right so you're
developing you're stacking your skills
and you're becoming proficient at it
Next Step you have to do repetition and
be being willing to get punched in the
face over and over and over again right
so that you can deepen those skills and
that's what amplifies the skills that
you have so that you can get to another
level
then as you get to another level then
your character traits need to be strong
so you can stay the course all right
like the biggest thing in the book uh by
Angela Duckworth called grit which is
really interesting
um is that the people who are most
successful in life just stick with it
like great stick to itness is what it is
so it's How likely are you to abandon a
certain path to pursue another thing
right and the people in the beginning
have very low stick with itness
entrepreneurs shiny objects shiny object
shiny object they're jumping from
opportunity to opportunity and they
never give any of the opportunities a
chance to be successful so one of the
interesting things that maybe you can
think about in terms of a quote that you
can take with you is
you can be successful anything you want
just not everything you want all right
that was a huge lesson for me all right
I had a I had a friend from high school
who reached out who had a contracting
business and a roofing business and they
were flipping houses so it's three
separate businesses and I was like dude
like like what do you want help with he
was like I don't know like what do you
think I should do and I was like pick
one he's like well we're making money in
all three of them and I was like cool
pick one each one of those businesses
can be a billion dollar business you can
be a billion dollar roofing company you
can be a billion dollar flipping Homes
company you can be a billion dollar
general contractor there are examples of
each of these things right but you just
can't be a billion dollars in all of
them and so there's a fallacy that we
tell ourselves as entrepreneurs which is
that if I do more things I will make
more money when in fact I need to do
fewer things to get to where I want to
go and the reason I can tell you that
it's the truth is because you naturally
think the other way and that's what most
people think which is why most people
aren't successful right is they they
can't focus because there's too many
things it's just so easy to just add
this one thing you do this other thing
and all of a sudden you're too super
thin you're not focused on amplifying
the things that you're doing to get
better you're not deepening the skills
you're spreading yourself thinner rule
number nine is make a living out of your
passion I've got employees that make
million bucks a year plus so like you
can absolutely become filthy wealthy and
that's income right and so a lot of
businesses that are at 10 million
dollars a year the owner might only take
a million bucks in income depending on
you know margins Etc and so like
a lot of a lot of employees will wish
for they see Top Line as income which is
just a very employee mindset
um they're like oh if I make six figures
a year I'll make six figures a year it's
like Well if you really want to make six
figures you're gonna probably make 500
Grand a year
um you know I mean revenue wise at least
if you don't want to have just bought
yourself another job right because so
let's let's talk through this transition
so if you're an employee when you make
the switch you're still an employee
you're just employee of a different
business that you happen to own and you
are basically 100 of the expenses and so
the business itself actually makes no
money you as the sole employee of that
thing and the boss
um gets to call your own shots but
you're still the employee right so
you're wearing all the hats Etc
um and so it's relatively nuanced you
know I mean like if you had a six foot
consulting job and then you start
Consulting on the side for example
through your own LLC you have the same
job you just got rid of the person who
is giving you Direction and that you are
responsible right the thing that most
people have to do is they have to go get
money right you have to go make money
and the way you do that is you sell
stuff right and the way that you can
even begin the conversation to sell
stuff is that you have to have people
who show interest in the thing which
means you have to make your products
known and we do that through advertising
right and there's five ways to advertise
which I which I just went over earlier
um and so it's like pick one of those
five ways
start doing it on a consistent basis
bring people in what do you sell them
that's what 100 million offers this book
is for it's like this is how you figure
out what to sell and then you sell them
the thing and then after that you'll
have some delivery now usually if you
have a consistent method of advertising
and selling with a without what to sell
from the offer then you can start
getting people to help you uh on the
level of delivery you have which comes
down to Breaking the delivery into
chunks rather than holistically and
saying how can I specialize the labor
because you trying to say I just need
somebody to do what I do is silly right
you need to figure out how could
somebody do how can I get how can I get
five people to do 20 of what I'm doing
and do it consistently right and then
you can increase your advertising sales
is a very high leverage thing in the
beginning if you spend all day selling
just you you would have enough for five
people to do work right and so then you
would have a business and Rule Number 10
the last one before some very special
bonus Clips is remove distractions the
most important lessons that I've learned
in my life have come from doing
and mentors
and so on a day-to-day basis it's
reducing the time between when you wake
up and when you begin working right A
lot of people lollygag and delay and
procrastinate and things like that and
if you just think about there's only a
certain amount of time in the day I want
to increase my output per unit of time
as much as possible a lot of people have
these superstitions that they have to do
a certain thing they must do X Y and Z
but all you have to do is talk to a
single mom who has like five kids and no
still start businesses they're not doing
any of that stuff they're waking up and
they're working before their kids are up
and then once their kids go to bed they
work then too right and they're not
doing all the lollygag stuff that you
know you see up trending all over social
media it's like they're working and so
like the single greatest skill in my
opinion is being able to find a place
that you can shut out external stimuli
and you can focus yes because for me the
singers like
the single highest Roi habit that I have
is that for me between 5am and noon I
have nothing on my calendar it is just
work no meetings and then all my
meetings happen after noon is this for
the entrepreneur if you're if you're
like in a job right now then it's got to
be in the morning before you go to work
and in the evening after you come back
from work but like
having that dedicated time and if you're
like well I'm not a morning person fine
then just work late like that's okay
like I've I've got billionaire buddies
who are like oh I wake up at 10. but
they work really late that's their
that's their special time that no one
bothers them it tends to be at the book
ends of the day though just from my
experience because in the middle of the
day you get pestered and it's hard to
get into that deep focus that really
that deep learning that you get when you
really pour yourself into something
I love the saying you know in our 20s
we're concerned about what everyone
thinks about us in our 40s we don't care
what anyone thinks about us and in our
60s we realize that no one was thinking
about us to begin with right and I just
I just feel like that's I mean who else
have you thought about today besides
yourself probably not I mean you have
your kids which is an extension of
yourself but you know what I mean like
yeah not a lot and so most people are
like that and you know
a lot of it like we have a lot more
leeway than I think we give ourselves
credit for and I think the more that I
have now you know I'll say accomplished
with quotes in in material success the
more I am excited about the things that
I can do and that was why the opening of
the book was like there are no rules and
it just took me a very long time to
realize that and I continue to unlearn
rules that I thought existed you know as
I continue to you know go on this
journey yeah I love that idea of
unlearning I think we all just try to go
back to being like we were when we were
children just because when you're a
child you're purely present you're just
present in the moment and I I don't like
the word happy very much I prefer using
Joy because you can be you can mourn
joyfully
right because it's it's a it's a it's
internal rather than happiness which I
feel is more like happenstance it's more
from external and so um you know one of
the things that bring me joy were the
things that I find you know to find joy
in
um and I think for anyone who's who's
listening it's a much harder question to
answer what are the things that bring me
joy than answering the question what are
the things I hate
and it's easier to correct those first
you're like well I hate my job and I
hate my relationship and I hate the city
okay those are all very changeable and a
lot of times you get there by by
inversion well if I wanted to destroy my
life I wanted to have the worst life
possible what would I do and then taking
all those things that you would do to
really destroy your life and make your
life miserable and then reverse them
it's a much easier way to solve the
positive psychology equation in my
opinion you need someone who you can
trust like if you're giving someone your
money like or you're trying to take
someone's advice or counsel you need to
trust their intentions all right and so
it's not just whether they have
integrity it's whether they have your
best interest in mind all right so I'm
going to get to how I solve for that in
a second but if that is the first
character trait of you need that you
need of a council of somebody of any
kind of counsel really whether it's
investment law Etc the second
um is efficacy or their skill set right
so let's think of both let's think of
just different scenarios here so let's
say you might trust your mom implicitly
but she doesn't have the skill of
knowing much about you know how to
structure insurance policies or trusts
or you know investments in Tech startups
right you might not have that skill but
you might trust her intention right for
you specifically on the reverse of that
you might see that there's this person
who's got lots of skill is prodigious in
this but it also means that they know
exactly how to screw you if they want to
right which is one of the double-sided
things of being really good at something
right you know all the details you know
how to write the agreement structure the
deals in order to make sure that you you
know get the best outcome right and so
the idea is to find someone who has both
your best interests at heart and has the
ability to deliver on what you want
right and so it's both of these things
and so you're like well yeah maybe that
seems obvious for me just even boiling
it down to that was very helpful for me
because when I look and I look through
advisors look for people I want to get
counsel from I have to look at these two
things all right so here here's how I
test for the Integrity piece and here's
how you can kind of like you can control
for risk here right one is I always try
and interview as many advisors as
humanly possible all right and I do that
because I'm going to get as much
information from each of the council
during this process that will give me
perspective from which to make a
judgment right one of the biggest
problems with this like if you think
about Julie who's trying to lose weight
right she goes to the gym and then she
talks this 10 personal trainers one
personal trainer says it's all about
high fat low carb another guy says hey
don't worry about that keto stuff it's
all about high carb low fat and then
another guy says no you really just need
a balanced thing and another guy says
it's only about calories it's only about
counting your Macros and so you get this
huge perspective so that hopefully you
can make a judgment call otherwise when
you talk to the first guy and he says
it's all about keto then you're like
well I guess this is it right I guess
these guys all have opinions when in
reality there is a truth you just don't
have the perspective in which to make a
judgment yet and so the first step in
this is that I interview as many as I
possibly can from reputable sources so
this is where I reach out to my network
I make posts Etc to try and get as many
referrals as I can alright so that's
step one step two for the Integrity
piece is that I try and have a line
incentives now a lot of times there are
incentive systems that appear aligned
but not are not in reality so let me
give you an example so in the real
estate market if you're a realtor for
example you may think oh this realtor
has my best interest at heart right
because they have an incentive to sell
the house and so that is why they're
going to get compensated so they want to
sell it for as much as possible ah but
they aren't incentivized to sell it for
as much as possible they're incentivized
to sell as fast as possible and get a
deal closed all right and so think about
this for you selling a house for 500 000
that's worth five hundred thousand
dollars is a normal you know that like
that's normal that's the market price
right but for you to make an extra let's
say twenty five thousand or fifty
thousand dollars would be really
material that would be a huge extra
outcome for you you would probably push
a lot harder to get the extra 25 or 50
000 now let's say that um you could
probably sell it in a day at four
hundred and fifty thousand dollars
because it's below the market value of
the house right now here's what's crazy
is that if a a selling realtor you know
like total it might be seven percent two
percent goes to the buyer and five
percent goes to the seller if five
percent is going to your realtor five
percent of 500 000 right is 25 Grand
okay and so for them the the fifty
thousand dollar decrease to drop you
from 500 to 450 means that they're going
to give up 2500 so they're gonna make
twenty two thousand five hundred so let
me ask you a question now the reverse if
they sell for 5.25 they're gonna get
twenty seven thousand five hundred right
and so it's a five thousand dollar swing
off of a you know twenty five thousand
dollar nut for them and one of them
might take them three months and one of
them might take them a day so what is
their incentive their incentive is to
get is to is to make as much money as
possible per unit of time and so they're
incentivized to sell as fast as possible
and so this is one of those things where
you have to put your thinking cap on and
say are our incentives truly aligned and
so when we're looking at this when I say
there's two aspects that I look for
counselor or somebody who's going to
help me do something financially legally
Insurance wise whatever it is so first
is that Integrity piece and are there
incentives aligned the incentives being
aligned and you could restructure that
deal and say hey you know what you're
going to get zero percent on anything
below 400 000 I'll give you three
percent on anything between 400 and 450
and then from 450 and up I'll give you
20 right or 15 or whatever right and so
now they're highly incentivized to push
and now your incentives are aligned
because each increment for you is worth
almost as much it is to them and that is
how you would align incentives all right
now how do you test for the second thing
which is their skill set
this one's hard all right especially if
you don't have the perspective from
which to make a judgment which when I
enter new things and I'm trying to learn
about trust and I'm trying to learn
about investment things and different
Vehicles I'm learning about storage
units more about multi like you're like
oh man there's so much stuff and there's
so much Nuance that you have to have
right and so the first thing is I like
to usually read two to three books on
the topic all right and I read two to
three books just so I don't appear like
an idiot
um and so I can at least understand what
they're saying and they're going to
respect you to they will it's kind of
like defense if you bring your if you
bring at least some level of knowledge
they don't feel like they're going to
take advantage of you so this is this is
the first thing that I do and this is
because I don't like feeling exposed in
these types of conversations the second
thing you can do is if you have someone
that you can trust you can bring them in
alongside you and the third thing that
you can do which is probably the the
most and highest recommended is
repeating the same action I said in the
first hand which is try and talk as to
as many of them as possible and then you
will gather the insights and you'll see
the people who demonstrate the most
expertise and what you can do is take
what one person says and say well what
about this and see what they reply with
right and as you gain gain more and more
knowledge and this is how you so in the
Consulting world this is qualitative
research right this is where you're
literally doing interviews essentially
to gather information so that you can
make an informed decision right and so
when you do these interviews and this is
what this is the lazy part this is what
most people don't do is they won't do
this work right they won't take the time
to interview 20 people or 10 people when
in reality these one decisions the guy
who you decide to you know invest in in
their fund or if you decide to buy this
building or invest in a fund that that
buys X Y and Z right or you'd or you
have somebody who who manages your
portfolio whatever it is right that one
decision can be one of the most if not
the biggest influence on your total net
worth over a long period of time and
people take more time to figure out what
they want to where they want to go on
vacation than where they're going to put
their money right and so my ask to you
is that if you if you put these put
these lenses on think about both of
these lenses lens one do I think this
person is Integris do I think this
person has my best interest at heart and
then two do they have the skill to
deliver on that promise because I don't
want my mom doing my Investments I know
she has my best at heart but she has no
idea what she's doing and then I don't
want somebody who absolutely knows what
they're doing and does not have my best
interest at heart right which honestly
unfortunately is a lot more of the cases
that that you'll come up with and
candidly you know a lot of times they're
literally incentivized against you you
know uh in the insurance industry
they're they're kind of incentivized to
rip you off it's it's it's pretty
terrible and there's a lot of Industries
like that mortgage brokers are
incentivized to rip you off and so you
really have to look at it from both
lenses and these types of decisions can
make the biggest impact on your net
worth and your financial future simply
based on who you decide to work with why
are you trying to change people's
perception of you when you can just
change who you are and let their
perceptions catch up the only way you're
going to change your reputation is by
being different he's like you need to
stop being this person that does all
these things and your reputation will
catch up and even if it doesn't you'll
always know and I honestly it barely
scratched the surface because my ego was
so high and I was like no I just have to
think of a better way to like Market
myself but I ended up knowing that he
was was very serious about the threat of
pulling me out of school if I didn't get
my grades up and so what I ended up
doing for the next half of the semester
of my first semester freshman year is I
didn't go out at all I didn't drink
anymore I really didn't like hang out
with girls at all and all I did was
study and I was able to pull my might
have been one two it was very low up to
a 3.2 for the semester which basically
meant I got an A on everything from that
point for the rest of the semester and
so when I went back home he was like
well now you know you can do it and so
we should always expect that that is
what you're gonna get from here on out
and it also kind of proved it to myself
too I was like I guess I can do this and
you know what happened is after I
started switching that way
people still thought of me as a
and I still had to deal with that it
took like two years to really reverse
the reputation that I had acquired in
the first three months I think during
that period of time I grew an
appreciation for how easy it is
especially in First Impressions to set
the wrong one and how hard it is to
overcome a negative impression and my
reputation overall the realization I had
was there's too many people that you're
interacting with in the world to try and
curate reputation
the only way to change your reputation
is to change who you are reputation is
fundamentally just what people say about
you to your face and behind your back
I'm not saying that you need to care
about what everyone else thinks that's
not really the point of this it's much
more if one person says you're an
whatever if every person you
know says you're Nestle like you might
be an and so if you have one of
those situations where you feel like the
proof or the evidence is overwhelming
and you might even believe it then it's
probably you I think that for me getting
out of the hole like I can control this
and try and curate what people think
about me and transitioning to be like at
the end of the day I'm the only person
who knows who I am and I don't like who
I am and just saying like well how can I
get to a point where I would like me
even if everyone else hated me how can I
like me when I started operating from
that place it really changed my life
because then I started thinking like
what version of me do I want to be and
what does that guy do well that guy
studies really hard and that guy works
out really hard and that guy's a really
good friend he's always respectful
doesn't have an ego and it took me a
long time and I still work on this stuff
you know what I mean I'm not saying I'm
done by any any sorts of imagination but
but I think that if you can simply shift
the perspective of like I'm going to try
and appear this way to like I want to be
this way if it just so happens to get
captured great and if it doesn't great
and there's this this quote that we
teach us that I'm probably gonna butcher
but he says if you need someone else to
tell you something about yourself you
are out of Integrity because you can
always be your own witness I think that
that's a great point to wrap the this
little video Lesson up with because that
piece strikes to the core of everything
which is we are our own Witnesses and if
we want to change our reputation we need
to change a reputation with ourselves
first and then eventually it will
reflect in the world there are a lot of
different things that come up in the
business world where I will see people
conflate or mistake what thing they are
solving right and most times when I'm
talking to a newer entrepreneur or even
a more established entrepreneur and they
reach out for help or guidance or
whatever right or it's one of our
portfolio companies most times they'll
start talking right really fast about
all this stuff to try and provide
context and I'll just usually pause them
and be like what problem are we solving
it usually gets them to stop right and I
would I would highly advise you if
you're if you're dealing with if you
have subordinates or you have direct
reports uh who roll into you and they
have a whole bunch of decisions a lot of
times it can get caught and sometimes
ourselves too we can get caught in the
in the day-to-day the minutia and just
simply pause and say what problem are we
solving there's so many pieces of this
that I want to impact that I think are
going to be really interesting for you
but the first one is when you define
what problems you are solving you may
even have to ask the question is that a
problem when some people are like well
hey we're getting you know customer
service complaints it's like okay
understood
is this something that we believe that
we can reasonably eliminate is this
something that is catastrophic to the
business or is this something that we
can kind of try and improve over time
you know through systems and process
right and so a lot of times people
misprioritize problems because they
perceive them as as threats to existence
when in reality they are a course of
doing business and things that be can
constantly improve right especially if
you're newer you're starting out of
course your product's not going to be
perfect yet right you're just getting
going
but you improve these things rather than
thinking I have to stop everything to
fix this problem right and so the first
frame shift is that most people think in
terms of like I have a problem to solve
rather than a dichotomy to be managed as
in these are two things that will always
exist all right I'll give you a
different example of this
um actually this will be a fun one the
reason we will probably never have
people who are all happy about a tax
code is because you cannot have both
fairness and equality equality means
everyone pays 10 percent fairness means
the rich people pay more than the poor
people that's fair this is equal both
are ideals and yet somehow they're not
the same thing and yet both are right
and so because of that we will always
have this conflict it's the same thing
between Justice and mercy both of them
are ideals both of them are right and
yet somehow they're conflicting and so
we we see these situations and this is
why I'm trying to hopefully give this to
you because the more I started to
recognize these patterns the more
quickly I can recognize them and then
identify them and then either dismiss
them or say oh it's another one of those
right it's a pattern recognition it's
like oh you guys are spending all this
effort trying to solve a problem that is
unsolvable this is a dichotomy that must
be managed and will never be eliminated
and so I think what like my goal with
this video is if I can help you get out
of these little mental hamster wheels uh
it's been incredibly valuable for me all
right so that's the dichotomy that's
like one of the one of the things that
people will mistake they'll mistake a
dichotomy for a problem that needs to be
solved all right
another framework
um that that I find immensely valuable
is the concept of of a Continuum versus
a binary all right this is probably one
of the biggest mental errors that people
make when they're trying to identify
things and this is what I mean by that
so for example I might say I'll use a
weight loss example so people will say
something like uh I am off my diet or
I'm on my diet right it's a very simple
thing and that's because psychologically
we like to be binary we like to label
things as yes or no but biology and
reality exist on continuums as in to
what extent did you go off of your diet
right did you go 200 calories average
you go 500 calories over and as even
though it is quote more difficult to
think in this way it is also more
accurate and so our brain uses binaries
as placeholders for decision making to
store data right when in reality when
you start storing all these binary
decisions they start adding up and you
start getting more and more unaccurate
if that's a word on your decision making
process because you're actually basing
your decisions not on facts but based on
binary shorthand that your brain saves
and so that is one of the biggest
mistakes that I see all the time in
thinking in entrepreneurs and really in
anything in general because we like to
have that shorthand it is easier right
it's easier to say I fell off my diet or
I am diabetic when the reality is it's
not whether you are a diabetic it's how
diabetic are you right kind of
interesting I stole that from Dr cashi
but I just love that who's my cluster
friend he's a biochemist and we talk
about this stuff all the time point
being if you can think about this within
um I'll give you I'll give you a
business example so if we have a a
binary where people are saying yes or no
which is let's say Facebook doesn't work
marketing doesn't work I hear these
statements all the time and you may
laugh at this right but I get DMs like
this all the time Facebook doesn't work
for me marketing doesn't work for me
like you can't sell this way in my
business right and so people want to
shorten a problem into yes it works no
it doesn't work when so much of business
and problem solving is understanding the
Nuance between where we're starting and
where we're going and it's to what
extent
has Facebook not worked right where is
the fall off right it is not that it
doesn't work it is just we only got it
to work this percent right now we need
to get all the way over the hump to get
there but it's to what extent and I
think that when I when if you if you can
ask the right questions if you can see
the problems as they truly are they
become far more solvable and so this has
been probably I just gave you two of my
my best frames that I think with all the
time all right so I'll say these again
so the first uh mental lapse I'll say
that I see all the time
is mistaking a dichotomy that needs to
be managed for a problem that needs to
be solved people do this in their
marriages as well right so you look at
your wife right you look at your wife
and you're like I need more variety
right but later you're like I need more
consistency and you're like we have to
figure this out we need variety we need
consistency it's like yes you need both
right and so it's not a problem to be
solved it's a dichotomy to be managed
how do we behave the reason that this is
so important is that it's one thing to
know where you're going but it's another
thing to know how you're going to get
there and so this is just as true in
business Partnerships and marriage in
terms of what you want uh to have happen
and how you want to get there
um as it is in business okay and so what
I want to do is actually just walk you
through the three values that we have at
acquisition.com and why we believe them
and so from an overarching perspective
the way to come to values
um is to look at what are the
non-negotiables okay and so what I mean
by that is and every company is
different because the core thing about
values is that they have to be things
that are true and innate to you right
like for example at Southwest uh have
fun is one of their core values and if
someone does not want to have fun or
does not believe in the processes that
they do to have a good time then that is
a non-negotiable for them that person
cannot work at that company it is a
fireable offense and so these are not
aspirational these are not things that
you would like to have these are things
that are core to who you are as a person
and as a team all right and so when you
decide on these non-negotiables they are
by their very nature non-negotiable
which means that you hire based on these
you Fire based on these and these are
the core Spirit of the team and some of
the mistakes that I see when people make
values is that one they don't draw the
line in the sand and so one of the core
things about a value is that it has to
you have to be able to say this is not
this right you have to be able to say
okay between Justice and mercy we lean
towards Justice or we lean towards Mercy
which means you have to repel people
with your values all right and so if
your values do not repel people well
then they are not values they are
platitudes okay and so it's very
important the next thing is that when
you're making your values the values
themselves need to be ideally said in
words that you would normally say so if
you have little sayings inside of your
community then then a lot of times those
can become some of the values you have
so for example a gym launch one of our
first portfolio companies uh speed is
King do the boring work these were
different ways I mean we could just say
work ethic but that's not the way we
would have said it we could have said be
fast or fast turnaround times but speed
is King was the way we would have said
it okay and so some of the things that
I've learned with this is also you
cannot have too many values as in I'll
say it differently you can have too many
values you have to be very selective at
the the true core values of the company
all right and so if you're you know
between two a lot of times you just have
to chunk up uh and kind of get a broader
value but they become the core and I
think that what we have found is that
three is The Sweet Spot and that number
is continued to distill down on over
time but I think three is the amount
that your human brain can comprehend as
lenses to make a decision right and the
reason these values are so important is
that when you scale the company you have
to scale decision making which means you
have to scale the frame with which you
duplicate the decision making process
which is should I hire this person even
though Alex is not involved in this do
they align with the core values and the
more stringent the values the easier it
is to have a black and white example of
I think this person means two out of the
three or one out of three but we only
accept three out of three and I will
tell you this as an additional point if
you have core values in the business I
would relay them to all aspects of your
life if you would not do business with
someone for a decade do not do business
with them for a day it's one of the
navalisms that I like a lot and so if
you wouldn't if you don't want to deal
with this client for a decade don't deal
with them for a day if you wouldn't deal
with this employee for a decade don't
deal with them for a day you have to and
and the extent to which you hold your
line of intolerance around these truly
non-negotiable vegetables will dictate
the health of the organization and if
you make these non-negotiables and
realize that there are people in your
organization in your client base that do
not ascribe to these then you must make
the changes to fix it and that is the
pruning of the tree that will ultimately
grow the tree all right these are the
short-term pains for the long-term gains
in a perfect world if everyone had
absolute information and everyone was
unbelievably well trained and you had a
great infrastructure and all that stuff
then yes the more products and services
you offer in theory you would make more
money but we don't live in that
theoretical world most of the time and
most small business owners are not that
good at operating right it's the number
one issue they have they're super
disorganized they feel like they're
spinning the reels all day their team
completely has no idea what which way
they're going they change things all the
time Etc and so in an effort to combat
that we have used this process over and
over again and it has worked very well
so it is as follows we sell two things
and I've done this in virtually every
business that I've ever owned we sell
two things two products or two services
and this is once we're going from one to
ten million all right zero to one
million you sell one product or one
service one Avatar all right that's it
one channel one product one Avatar
that's it right but once you're going
from one to you know one to three ish
million and you're trying to go to ten
you introduce the second product line
and so here's how this works if you have
two things that you sell you'll have a
front-end thing and you'll have a
back-end thing we can still have a
massive accommodation in the buying
curve based on the payment terms that we
introduce so for example people will
look at their monthly expense more than
the total contract value that's a huge
money hack I'm giving you right now this
is a wealth hack this is something that
will build make you a fortune in your
life if you can properly understand this
people do not look at the length or the
total contract they're signing they will
only pay attention to what is it going
to cost me every month because no one is
good with their money all right so they
only look at the cash flow expense month
over month over month and they just
think can I make it happen yes cool I'll
sign they don't think about the total
contract value for you as a business
owner the contract value matters almost
more than anything so I'll give you a
quick hack on this total side note
tangent for you life hack Pro tip if you
want to extend the contract value that
you have I have a saying which is the
bigger the head the longer the tail all
right and so what that means is the more
you can get someone to pay up front and
relative to The Upfront cost of signing
up or what they paid down
the lower their contractual recurring
payment is the stickier it will be so
I'll give you an example if I had
someone sign up for 99 a month for
whatever it doesn't matter that price
point might be medium sticky depending
on the value that I have now imagine I
had someone pay five thousand dollars
down and 99 a month after that how much
more sticky would it be significantly
more sticky now the beauty is if you
have one of these upfront type payments
you can also use that to liquidate your
ad costs cover your commissions for the
salesperson cover The Upfront
fulfillment and onboarding which is
going to cost more for a new customer
than an existing customer and so you can
build all that in if you know that the
thing that you are selling has very high
gross margins then you can still have a
lower cost as long as you know that the
person is going to stay for a long time
and So based on how you structure the
pricing you can actually get some you
can use the pricing to actually get
people to stick longer Pro tip complete
that is it moving back to the original
thing that I was talking about in one of
our portfolio companies we actually had
this as a really in-depth discussion
that we had to make a decision about all
right and so they had a different you
know Mentor person whatever advice uh
who told them that they should have
three products and they should have uh
you know low a medium and a high product
and then based on uh you know what the
salesman thought the salesman would sell
them the low medium or high in my
experience it is not that effective and
that is because the salesperson can't
decide which of these things they are
trying to sell most of the time and so
what we have found is more effective is
you give the salesperson the one dream
to sell this thing is going to solve
this person's problem and we make it the
most valuable thing that we're trying to
sell because at the end of the day a you
do want to solve the the customer's
problem right we do want to actually
make sure that we're providing value
rather than having a diet a medium and a
great right Simply Having one thing that
solves all the problems and then based
on the the customer's budget we can
decrease how they pay all right so hear
me out so let's say that uh we want to
do a uh this is a six-month
implementation of whatever kind of
solution you sell if you have a six
month duration you can have the person a
pay the entire thing up front so that
would be for somebody who has the
highest budget version two would be a
split pay version three might be three
payments right with at twenty percent
higher and then finally you might have a
have a have a you know a six pay or
whatever over that period of time so one
two three six now here's the cool thing
the more payment options you provide the
higher your conversions are that's
proven all right so the more options you
give someone to pay the more people will
buy
period now you might not make more cash
flow because if you give your sales guy
more options then they might use they'll
end up defaulting to the lower ones
right but if you have one thing to sell
then they only have one thing to
convince the person of because a
confused mind doesn't buy if you have
too many options the salesman won't know
what to sell and the prospect won't know
what to buy and so I prefer when I'm
coming into a portfolio company I'm
thinking what is this true problem that
we are solving with this business for
what Avatar and we make that the main
thing and we communicate it clearly in
the scripting and the salesperson has
Clarity on what they are selling and
they're always solving the same thing
and so the question becomes no longer
which of these things are you going to
buy but once you are buying how would
you like to pay and so then the
discussion is around what payment plan
is best for them rather than what
product is best for them and so by doing
that you can get people to go between
different payment terms that is not
going to change whether they're going to
buy but if they're unsure about which
product is going going to best suit
their needs and the salesman doesn't
know because at the end of the day he's
just trying to sell the most expensive
thing then you'll have way more confused
people who leave unsold so this is a
single tactic that you can use to
execute within your business which is
why I'm a big fan of making offers
people cannot say no to is that you can
focus all of your sales and all of your
persuasion attempts on selling the one
thing which is getting them to say yes
once they say yes we can we can reach
the we can accommodate their wealth and
their budget based on the payment terms
that we provide and if we have done we
have structured our offer properly the
offer in and of itself should already be
very high gross margins which means
whether or not the person pays a
thousand dollars a month or a hundred
dollars a month it's still almost all
margin for us because of how we
structure the thing that we are selling
and so we are able to capture Higher
ltvs by getting the people who have more
money to prepay the thing up front that
is how we do it and with those people
you'll be able to ascend into the second
thing faster because they've already
prepaid that thing and then you can
solve the next natural problem in
another sales conversation rather than
trying to pick all of the things in one
conversation which makes it incredibly
difficult to do this is just for
everyone again a broad brush stroke of
statements for most entrepreneurs who
are not very good at operating their
businesses uh her operations is not
their strong suit and are below three
million dollars a year Envy is having
the the desire
for something that someone else has that
you do not have so you're lacking and
someone else has something that you want
and do not have that is envy jealousy is
when you have a threat that somebody is
going to take something that you have
that they do not have all right and so
for example I'll give you an example of
each so Envy I may be envious of a
friend of mine so I was actually talking
to a good friend of mine who owns a big
weight loss company and right now he's
doing better than I am and now I am
envious of his success I am I can feel
it I'm envious I got off the phone I was
like I'm envious of you right on the
flip side if someone comes to talk to
Layla right it is the fact that they
pose the threat of taking attention or
her attention that I think should
continuously belong to me that I would
feel jealous over I haven't had I
haven't felt jealousy in a long time but
that is that is an example it could also
be like with your kids if you have some
you know some other adult in their life
starts taking their attention or has
more influence over them you are jealous
of the influence that that person is now
is threatening your influence over your
child right so two examples they're
nuanced but I think it's important
and when I was talking to Nick barely
about this I was talking about how I
think Envy um gets a bad rap and I'm not
going to go into the spiritual religious
side of this or even the happiness side
of this because I think Envy absolutely
does not make you happy
but I do think that Envy will make you
successful all right and so this this is
where I want to kind of dive into this
Envy is adaptive right as human beings
this is actually from our old brain
right this is animals have this too they
are envious of one another and it's
because if in a group one person or one
being one animal whatever brings more to
the table you are now envious of that
person and what it does is it elevates
the rest of the group to go and achieve
the same which is good for the
collective not happier for each of the
individuals but is a pro survival tool
right and so for me understanding this
and at least being able to name the
emotion rather than saying I don't like
this guy or I'm angry at this person or
having this negative feeling that you
cannot put words to instead being able
to say I am envious has been very
relieving for me because now I can
actually tell those people hey I'm
envious of you and for some reason I
think it just creates another level of
Candor because it's a certain level of
vulnerability and saying you have
something that I wish I had but then
you'll notice that the conversation is
not defensive on that person's part most
of the time they're like well let me
help you
and it's only when we guys our
intentions or trying or trying to feign
you know pretend to be a different way
than we are where people also can sense
that you're being disingenuous like
great job man right when you realize
deep down and they can tell from your
your subtle tonality changes and the way
you look that the um that you're
actually not happy for them right and so
I think if you can at least say it then
it actually gives you power now
in terms of judging your motivations
because obviously you might think that
Envy is a bad uh motivation
it is my belief that I would rather deal
with people who do good things for bad
reasons than bad reasons for good things
um or I said the same thing twice but uh
they do the right thing for the wrong
reasons rather than the wrong things for
the right reason all right I'd rather
someone who does the right outcome and
he gave me an example that was really
powerful he said a friend of his was a
top Navy SEAL
and uh you know one of the best Navy
Seals he trains Navy Seals just a total
badass right and before that he was an
EMT
and he talked about his experiences
being an EMT is that most people think
you know EMTs have to be really caring
that you want them to you know they have
to save these people's lives every day
and he said uh the Navy SEAL was saying
I was not compassionate at all I didn't
really care that much about the person
who was on the table in front of me but
what I did care about was my stats I
cared about the status of being the best
I wanted to have the fastest to the
hospital I want to have the highest
survival rates highest success rates of
the people that were under my care
because I cared about myself being the
best and so the question is if you were
the person who was on the table having a
heart attack would you rather have the
compassionate EMT or would you rather
have the self-interested EMT who is
doing it for status well if it were me
I'd rather have the guy who wanted to
Pride himself on being the best in the
world and didn't even care about me at
all because I knew his result was going
to be more Pro me than the other persons
and so I think that as as humans as
entrepreneurs we judge ourselves a lot
on our motivations and our in our
intentions but I think that if we can
take a step back and a name the emotion
so that it's not this amorphous thing
that we can understand but then take the
next step and say is this is this a
pro-adaptive uh emotion is this
something that's going to help me or is
this an emotion that's going to drive me
to do something that is negative and I
think at least even even in naming that
we can increase the time between emotion
and action and the further that time Gap
is in general
the better the quality of the decisions
we make because the more rational we are
we're never completely rational because
we're we're emotion driven beings and we
have limbic systems that override things
but the more we can decrease the
triggers the emotional triggers that
that cause us to make bad decisions
ultimately the better decisions we make
and so
I I say all this to say big picture
first naming the emotions is important
second it creates space so we can make
better decisions third we can analyze
those decisions and say is this
something that is going to help me in my
life or is this something that's going
to hurt me and then as a result of this
we don't have to judge ourselves as
strongly on why we are doing things and
rather what is being done because
candidly I am a very envious individual
and maybe this is me just
um
rationalizing my own negative you know
emotions who knows
um but at least for me
saying it that way and framing the
thought process in that way has helped
me feel uh better about myself
um and just not or really just less bad
if that's probably a better way of
saying it and not constantly berating
myself for having desires that I think
are wrong and so uh Dan Sullivan said
this and I'll end with this is that
when people want something if you want
to make more money if you want to have a
bigger house you want to have a bigger
car you want to build a podcast Studio
whatever right
he said wanting is reason enough
because so many times we ask but why do
we want that
we're probably not going to change the
desire
and so letting us letting ourselves
desire things and giving ourselves
permission to desire things uh and
myself specifically
um has been incredibly freeing and what
it's done is given me a tremendous
amount of my attention back that used to
be allocated to analyzing why I'm
feeling this way or why this is right or
why this is wrong and instead accepting
the fact that I want something and that
wanting it is okay as long as it is not
something that is hurting other people
and that it's not something that is
hurting me I actually don't think about
it much I think a lot of people spend a
lot of time and effort trying to figure
out how they feel because they want to
then judge or label themselves as I'm
doing well or not well like a lot of
effort goes into something like how do I
feel about this I mean my father should
be like why do you care why does it
matter and that's why when you ask way
longer about like how much do you think
feelings matter I don't think they
matter at all
like what would the case for feelings
mattering be then why do you believe
they exist it's a good question and it
gets really interesting because it's
like how I experience a feeling that I
label in my head as sadness is it the
same way you experience the thing that
you let it's like seeing green and I see
green and you see green what if all of
our greens are different right I mean
it's it gets very interesting like that
but I think that I experienced something
and if we were to just measure it based
on like brain activity and like heart
rate I would say that I become aroused
in the literal sense uh from
experiencing what I would deem as
emotions and so if we were to describe
it or Define the term in that way I
think I experience emotions and so I
mean I'm fairly confident I experience
emotions if we were to try and measure
it that way then that's how I would say
yes I do experience them but the
question is just like how important are
they and then it would be like for what
if it's for accomplishment not very
important for Fitness not very important
you know if if we're saying how
important is emotion for love which is
another emotion right it becomes like
amorphous trying to go to amorphous but
then you say okay well for defining Love
by AI what I'm willing to endure to
continue to keep something then how
important is it well it depends on how
much I've conditioned myself to accept
this thing so like if I want to stay
married it's probably far more effective
to condition someone to stay married
because that is the external consequence
of a good marriage as you stay together
right I'm just saying like we're just
purely measuring from from external
circumstances and so I think trying to
measure and Define things is what I
actually geek out on and I really enjoy
I think most people get boarded tears
when I talk about this stuff so I don't
talk about it much but that's the stuff
that like um when when we keep peeling
back layers of like why do you think
you're able to get out of you know a
difficult place in your life or why do
you think you're able to go through
these things a lot of it is because I
believe that I will redefine terms and
so we'll have some instance or something
that I should do and I will redefine it
or I'll say I I don't should I can just
accept it and that's why the biggest
refrain that I have in my head for like
my own mental illness is just like and
that's okay period
like I don't want to go to that thing
that's okay I think that the whole ego
death concept that we were talking about
the very beginning I try not to talk
about this too much because I think it's
it's um a lot of people find take
offense to it and I don't mean it that
way I sure this is just what worked for
me and not as a criticism of any anyone
else's beliefs for me the idea that
there was no such thing as Legacy that
when I died eventually everything that I
had would become dust and that anything
expanded over a long enough time Horizon
disappears right which if you are like
Christian for example it's the whole
book of Ecclesiastes
um
if you and I think the realization of
that allowed me to quiet my ego a lot
um so that I could be more present in
the idea that like this moment will only
be here in my mind and anything that I
do here will not last and so it shifted
how I worked it shifted how I saw
relationships and a lot of my thinking
is around like my 85 year old self I
feel like my number one Mentor is like
my fictitious 85 year old self because
it's the only person that I really
believe has my best interest at heart
and is no ulterior motive and so there's
this this tweet that I had that went
pretty viral but it was like
listening to a billionaire or a
millionaire I'll just use that like when
I was in my 20s I wanted to be a
millionaire and when I was a millionaire
I wanted to be in my 20s
and so the idea that my future self
would trade all the money he had to be
poor in 20 again made me really
reanalyze how I saw living life in the
moment if I literally in the future will
value my present moment more than the
achievement of the thing that I'm I'm
seeking right now in the present
then something's something's off because
even my future self knows that because
right now I would pay all the money I
have to get 10 years back
it's not even thinking about it and so
then all of what I'm going to achieve in
the next 10 years I would happily give
up to be right where I am right now
and so I think thinking about that
really shifted a lot for me because it
helped me quiet I'm not saying eliminate
but quiet some of the thoughts that are
more ego driven because the ego always
wants to like separate and isolate from
others and prove that it's better and if
I know that it will all be dust there is
no better because we're all going to be
destined so in that same way if like if
we're all going to be Dustin we're all
siblings like two very strong frames for
me at least it helped me quiet that
aspect and I think in that way I was
able I think you can ask my people but
like I think I was able to show up
better as a leader there's been able to
shop better as a husband
um so I better like to make content
things like that like I don't think I
could have made the stuff we make now
five years ago because I still think it
would have been more it would have been
to proving something yes perfect 100 of
improving proving someone proving a
fictitious foe wrong
right right they're all talking about
right no one cares about you exactly and
so that was really and it's like I had
to shift from like no one cares about
you to
like
I really want to have a shirt that says
no lives matter but I feel like
no one cares about you yeah yeah but I
feel but I think there's like a lot of
like meat to that where it's like if we
can because in that way we are all equal
and so it's I think it's almost the most
egalitarian perspective is that like in
the end we will all be dust yeah and so
I think in that way that's like we have
these exchanges that we have
um and in some ways it makes it more
beautiful when I started in this
business I took every single sale and it
was because I was so afraid that
somebody would waste the opportunity so
if you have that fear I understand where
you're coming from second when I had my
first sale that was not me I I just had
this emotional breakdown because I was
like oh my God this could actually
happen and I promise you if you haven't
had it happen yet you will when it does
because you realize that this business
can actually work without you and other
people can make it rain too right and
then I'll tell you a quick story that
illustrate the next point then to make
so as I you know hired some sales people
now that first sales person were they
exceptional no but they were able to get
the job done later on I had my first
kind of like killer and his name was
Mario negretti and he uh he came in
I don't know a year or two into the
business a year into the business and he
so quickly was able to assume the sales
role and to show you how laughable this
is he started and I was about to start
training him and some lady walked in the
door and I was like hey man like I can
take you he's like no I'm good he's like
go do your thing he's like Fitness
Nutrition accountability okay I'll
figure it out and he ended up closing
this first lady who walks in the door
for a paid in full and I remember
walking in like completely dumbstruck I
was like he didn't even know what the
pitch was but she walked out giggling
happy so excited to start and would that
moment taught me was that
it is good to train sales people but
it's better to take great sales people
and then just point them in a direction
and so this has informed a lot of the
thinking that I have Around Talent in
general and I'll tell you a couple of
Frameworks that have informed this but
like if you look at Harvard Harvard
doesn't produce the smartest people they
select the smartest people and then they
put smart uh professors in front of them
but like the base level of intelligence
of everyone who's at Harvard is already
exceptionally high and so like even if
the teachers at Harvard were not
exceptional the students are and they
would be successful independent of that
because their selection is so ridiculous
right and so if we can think about our
own companies that way and especially if
you're in the service business like look
at the biggest service companies out
there like look at McKinsey look at Bain
look at BCG look at basically a lot of
the finance world is or service-based
businesses a lot of times right and
they're able to do that because they
create such a pool to select from that
they are able to skim for the best
talent right I heard this uh quote from
uh es true Kathy who's the founder of
Chick-fil-A you win the championship in
the draft and so it was such a belief
that they had about picking the right
people even more so than training and I
would say that I have moved in that
direction of a little bit more nature
than nurture when it comes to roles
specifically sales especially there are
certain characteristics about building
Rapport about having certain you know
Dynamics or energy whatever you want to
say that like Mario negrady when he
walked in he had all of these things and
he didn't even know the pitch but he won
that sale off of Just Pure Rapport and
so if I'm going to allocate the same
level of time to training somebody I
might as well start with somebody who
has a much higher base because I could
spend 10 hours to take someone from a
two to a four and a half or I could
spend the same 10 hours taking someone
from a six to a nine and the thing is
I'm also going to get more bang for my
buck in terms of my hours of training
with somebody who has natched a natural
Liberty for selling compared to somebody
who does not what's interesting about
this and this is just like my
observation is that you just have to be
willing to talk to more people in the
recruiting process I will say like from
a recruiting standpoint there's there's
two kind of things to look out for if
you're if you're if you cannot pay super
handsomely based on your price points
which you need to maybe fix later but
like if you can't pay super well for the
sales person then you need to look
harder and you'll need to interview more
people and you'll need to probably run
ads and use your network if you can pay
well the best sales people are already
employed and so it comes down to
recruiting those sales people from other
sales jobs ideally from companies just
like yours so that they already know a
lot of the things coming into it so it
decreases the ramp up time for them
because all we were really doing is
swapping products and the actual sales
cycle the type of sale is at a
transactional sales and a long sales at
a software sales is it a coaching
program set whatever it is right there's
so few variables that were changing that
they can immediately Jump and Go which
also allows you to make adjustment on
their proficient you faster and so as a
quick side note to this because this is
something that I've given a lot of
thought if you look at the top sales
people and sales trainers and this is
going to drive Point Drive home the
point that I was making earlier about it
being much of it being born all right is
that if you look at the top people who
are in the space you look at Jordan
Belfort right you look at Bradley you
look at and some people would would say
me in term from a selling perspective
all the guys that I know who have taught
sales were exceptional sales people day
one Bradley started selling cars when he
was 18 years old and was the top
salesman at 18 years old when he started
and he was like I just found something I
was really good at Jordan Belfort talks
about how you didn't know how to train
anybody in his book and then all of a
sudden he for the first time ever wrote
out a framework to explain the straight
line sale system which became his book
and all that kind of stuff but he up to
that point it was just what he naturally
did right and I can tell you in my
instance as well I'd already closed
thousands of deals before I even
consumed my first sales training and so
like I I do think that if we are
selecting sales people I think it's much
more about selection than it is about
training the training is to remind them
how good they are not necessarily to
make them good all right and this is
something that has shifted over time for
me specifically now if you're like well
I suck at sales you can absolutely put
way more time into yourself than a
business would recently put into an
employee all right like you have you all
the time so you can train you in all
your off hours and you're spending your
own time to invest in yourself but from
a return on investment perspective it's
the cost of finding a good salesperson
compared to the cost of training a bad
or mediocre sales person is
significantly lower it's much easier to
find the right people than it is to take
somebody and then make such a crazy
extensive training unless your entire
model is we just take on every single
person who walks in the door like 24
Hour Fitness has this model they take on
anybody who has a pulse and then they
put them through a ridiculous culling
process and then 10 of people make it in
the first 90 days the number one thing
I've struggled with my entire life is
ego
and it's a topic that I don't know I
feel like it gets talked a lot more in
the woo-woo world than it does in like
the entrepreneurial world but you know I
think like ego kills profits ego Pride
kills profits that's a that's a much
more quotable uh thing uh so pride pride
kills profits and a lot of it is because
like we care more about being right than
serving the other person and there's
this quote about humility that um shoot
I can't remember the guy's name but um
he's the guy who wrote uh I think
disruptive innovation he was a Harvard
Business School Professor I think his
first name is Christian anyways very
very smart guy
um and he said humility is not thinking
less of oneself but increasing your
regard for others
and that was a really useful definition
for me because it's you know it's not
about pushing yourself down it's about
raising everyone else up and I think
that
um there has been some podcasts that
have gone really well like there's a
school of greatness podcast with Lewis
house that I think is really really good
that's going to come out soon
um there's a podcast
the ice coffee Hour podcast with graham
Stefan and Jack Selby on their channel
uh which you can check out is I think a
really good podcast or at least I've
gotten a lot of positive feedback from
it
and I was trying to look at like what's
the difference between those ones and
the ones that I come off
you know douchier and you know I'm
partially exploring this out loud with
you guys because like I don't know if
there's times where you're you know not
coming off the way you want to or you're
like not in the right mood or you're
just you're not the best version of you
you know what I mean and I I'm kind of
making this because
I think you know I I feel like just from
the comments and the posts and the tags
and things like that like imagination
and I love you guys to death I think
there are some times where you put me on
a pedestal like I
I am I am something that I am not you
don't even like I am very flawed
um and I and I work at it you know what
I mean um and I fail a lot and ego has
been one that I've struggled a lot with
and it was the thing that really
isolated me you know when I was younger
uh because I definitely you know and I
think ego is another way of saying
insecurity
um of just you know wanting to prove
that you're better than people because
deep down you don't feel like you're
good enough and so
for me uh that's been a struggle uh my
entire life and it's been just a I see
it much more as a war than I do a uh a
battle you know what I mean so you know
Wars have many many battles in them and
at this point I'm definitely not
undefeated so it's much more about like
I'd like to have more W's than L's uh in
the in the wins and losses column around
this and I think I've just had a lot of
L's lately and so
I'll just explain to you what I think
you know my process of what I'm going to
try and think of around this you know in
the future is that um I'm going to try
and
level set before I get on interviews and
so I put a little checklist in my phone
of like hey humility is increasing your
regard for others it's caring more about
the audience it's caring more about the
other person than being right
um and uh and it's it's it's ideally
just lifting up everyone around you and
it's just you know I think there's just
this part of me that always screams out
and wants to you know prove something
and I'm sure that you know a lot of the
material success has come from this
place and I don't think it's a positive
place I think it's a negative one
um
or rather it's a you know an emotion
that that I wouldn't say is a pool it's
a when I see positive negative I should
redefine it as it is an away from fuel
rather than a towards fuel like most of
my motivation has been trying not to
feel like a failure
um in my own eyes
um than it is to you know pull towards
something I'd like to when I operated my
best self I think I have more pool
motivation but I still think that
there's a significant part of me that is
driven away from things and driven away
from pain I say this because all of us
right I do this I do this all the time
right and this is going to be repeated
theme because it needs to be repeated
right we need to be reminded more than
we need to be taught that is a saying
that we have in my world and I will I
will pass it on to you guys Mosey Nation
we need to be reminded more than we need
to be taught do the boring work repeat
successful actions and so
if he's gotten to this point or if
you've gotten to a point in your
business and it has plateaued the
question is has it plateaued because
this is true like I have the only reason
a business should Plateau that is
reasonable that is not your fault is
that you have reached the total
addressable Market as in you have
saturated the total the total Market of
that thing so for example if you were
selling dog food and every dog within
this you know maybe you saw a specific
type of niche of poodle food right
you've gotten you know 70 of poodle
owners to buy your food and you can't
grow anymore beyond that right well that
would be reasonable but then you'd
obviously just do a different type of
dog right you'd you'd hop verticals
right so there's not even a reason but
it would be the only potentially
rational reason
um would be uh that your Market uh has
changed so a different example is a
friend of mine owns a company that does
uh newspaper advertising right so they
actually help newspapers translate their
advertisements into digital products
which is pretty cool so they are able to
sell a whole like basically a whole new
ad product to small businesses um who
want to buy ads right which is by the
way how newspapers make money he could
not grow his business because newspapers
have shrunk by 25 year over year which
is 25 compounding the wrong direction
and he's been in that business for like
10 years so now the market size is like
literally like five percent of what it
used to be 10 years ago and so as a
result of that he was growing at an
inverse rate to the shrinkage of the
industry right and so he got to a point
where he couldn't grow anymore than just
basically servicing the ones that are
still alive and then as they fell so did
his business right and so that is the
only logical reason that a business can
Plateau that is not in your control and
unless you're selling your newspapers
which are probably not the reason is
much simpler which is you just don't
know how and I'll tell you a different
story that I had and then I'll I'll I'll
wrap this up at the end so I was having
a different conversation with a woman
who was doing I think four million
dollars a year and she was selling uh
info products that were weight loss like
weight loss info products so like
programs and ebooks and things like that
which is cool right she's a big
following all that kind of stuff and we
got I went I did a podcast with her and
uh after we got off the podcast she was
like yeah so these are my plans I'm
going to be doing like an apparel line
and a supplement line and uh cream line
and whatever right and I just kind of
sat there and I was like well I think
that's a terrible idea she was like she
just looked at me across there she's
like what I was like yeah I think it's a
terrible idea and she was like oh and I
was like why don't you just take the
thing that's making you four million
dollars and make it make you 10 million
dollars
when you do that
and the and the answer is the same as
the first answer I just don't know how
and I was like right well why don't we
solve that problem
and then not create a new business why
don't we just put all of our effort in
solving that problem and so I'm a big
believer and this is the the piece that
I want to share with you Emoji nation is
that I'm a big believer in the theory of
constraints which means that a system
will grow until it is constrained right
it has a constraint and then once you
remove the constraint it will continue
to grow right until it reaches another
constraint and so most people are always
curious or many people ask me hey Alex
how did you achieve quote so much in
quote such little time or at such a
young age and I say all that in quotes
because so much could be and young age
whatever but I'm saying I'm just I'm
paraphrasing all right and I think that
um one of the things that we have done
well is prioritizing what problems to
solve
and that is understanding the
prioritization of problems and realizing
that there is really only typically one
or two things that are constraining our
growth and by definition there'd really
only be one thing that's the constraint
until we reach another thing that might
be beginning to constrain us but isn't
the true constraint yet mortality has
been the single biggest driver and the
biggest decisions that I've made in my
life and it has become a more routine
process for decision making for me in
general because I think it it provides
Clarity and it provides context to most
of the decisions we have which the vast
majority of them don't matter which is
helpful in and of themselves and then
you know beyond that it helps me make
the decisions that I think removes
everyone else from The Playbook because
if you if you study subjective
well-being and how people perceive how
they're doing in their own lives it
looks like a smiley face so
seven-year-olds think they're killing
life and then it drops dramatically
between 20 and 30 and then there's still
a little bit more of a dip right around
45 that's like when people are their
true they hate life the most and then
and then it kind of slowly goes up to
like 55.60 and then it shoots right back
up again when people see that they're
going to die and that life is short and
that they can make the decisions without
worrying about the ramifications of
other people and some of the people
they're worried about are also dead and
so it was using that context for that
biggest decision that's been duplicated
many times in my life since then because
if I have a good decision-making
algorithm I try and reuse it as many
times as I can there's a a tweet by
Layla my wife she said like stop
listening to people about like sorry
stop listening to people about how to
play the game who've never been anywhere
but the sidelines and the problem is too
many of the people who are watching this
right now y'all are on the sidelines and
have always been on the sidelines and
are trying to pick a niche to get into
to sell how to do the niche well that's
dumb you've never done it so a lot of
times people are trying to skip to a
higher leverage opportunity without
having done the requisite work of
understanding the niche which is why the
Y combinator people look for like if you
want to make a software in the payment
space we'd love to see that you have
experience in the payment space because
there's so much stuff that you don't
know that you know when you actually
spend three five you know years doing
something in an industry you understand
the lingo you understand the Avatar you
understand the problems and you can see
opportunities if you have an
entrepreneurial hat on there's always
problems in every industry which means
there's always opportunity and
fundamentally business is just solving
problems that exist with it and making
sure the math makes sense like that's
literally it it's like where is there a
problem how much did they think this is
a problem and is there a way that I can
solve it and charge for it that's it
like that's that's really all that
business is and really how well you
solve the problem is going to dictate
how much virality your business has
because if you solve it really well
people will tell people and your your
business will grow right I think the
problem that a lot of people have is
they didn't know how to make an offer
right is the fundamental thing that is
the beginning of building a business is
you got to know what you're selling and
so that was a problem for a lot of
people and then people got that problem
solved and then they told their friends
and both sold 100 000 copies in six
months with no promotion and so I'm only
I'm sharing this because I couldn't
write a book on offers without having
made a ton of offers and I feel like
there's too often people who are trying
to focus on a niche who've never
actually done the thing in the niche and
this is really really rampant in the
Internet space because everyone's trying
to take a shortcut to get there when
they realize like what I'm telling you
right now you're never going to get
there because you're not good enough
like you're never going to get there
because you're not good enough you have
to do the Rocky cut scene you have to
eat this for a period of time so that
you can get the Reps in so you can put
your time under the bar in so that you
can actually get good and before you are
good you will suck and you have to
accept long period of sucking and you do
enough volume that eventually you'll
suck so little that you'll actually be
good and then at that point then you'll
actually have a real decision to make
which is I'm actually really good at
this thing now that I've learned do I
want to teach it to other people or just
want to do more of the thing that I'm
doing right because like a realtor can
then just grow a team of 100 Realtors
and own the entire thing which is what
I'd recommend this guy do right rather
than have an agency um that doesn't
right and so this is kind of where where
I think the problem is is that like I
had another question that was sent to me
on Instagram which is like Hey how do I
soft churn because a lot of my a lot of
my clients are getting results and I'm
like well duh he's like I know he said
he said how do I sell from 10 000 to 100
000 a month when I don't have a lot of
testimonials I was like
you're not good at the thing that you're
supposed to be good at it's why I don't
have testimonials it's why you're not
going 100 000 a month like he's making
the goal a hundred thousand dollars a
month rather than being good
I I have no words I have no words I
don't get it you know what I mean like
everyone's in such a rush that you will
never get there it is the slowest path
to getting there is to fool yourself and
thinking that you're good something that
you're not you have to go and pull the
thread and say which and the thing is is
like well do what you're passionate
about whatever you're not gonna be
passionate about stuff that you suck at
what you have to do is like which of
these opportunities seem like they have
potentially have high leverage and I'm
gonna learn from the bottom right it's
like one of the best ways to learn stuff
is starting at the bottom not because
because it's the only option but because
if you understand the entire pathway of
of a client Journey or of an industry
Journey then you will have more trench
knowledge more depth of experience that
you will be then able to apply people
see my you know videos on Personal
Finance people see videos of mine on
sales people's videos online recruiting
people see videos of mine of marketing
and it's like how did you acquire all
these skills it's because like it's not
like because I tried to jump to the spot
that I'm at you can't skip like there's
a sequence buildings are built with
foundations and your career is a pyramid
in the peak of that pyramid is based on
the depth of the foundation that you
build and so like I've said this before
and I'll say it again but your work
works on you more than you work on it
and so even though you might not be
getting paid in the period that you're
at just because you're struggling
doesn't mean you're failing and it means
and the thing is as long as you're
getting better you're making progress
and the progress is the success is that
you are getting better and like you will
turn the corner like that's an
inevitability if you put enough time in
one of the things that I've seen across
the board when we're talking to
entrepreneurs and you know the the
general community that we have is that
the one trait I see over and over again
that is clear to the people who are are
winners right the top one percent I'm
not talking top 10 but the top one
percent is the speed with which they
execute after making a decision one of
the definitions that like we talk about
in the community is that definition of
power as I understand it is the gap
between thoughts becoming reality and so
if you thought about an omnipotent being
right something someone who has
unlimited power as they think that thing
would be right and so if you were to
believe in a creator of some sort then
you might think as that Creator thought
the universe became right and so if you
think that as like the ultimate scale of
power then the closer we can get to that
the more powerful we become the more
potent we are as entrepreneurs and so I
see this so many times that it's it's
not even it's not even a oh like this is
associated with success like this is
what creates success because the gap
between where you decide something is a
good idea and when it actually occurs is
the loop with which you can improve your
business and so it's a lot like I can't
remember what the saying was but it's
it's not like how old the cars but about
how many miles are on it what I mean by
that is like We're Young right but
there's been a lot of a lot of
iterations that have happened from you
know when the business first started
when I started my first gym until now
and I think the key to that is the speed
of the ooda loop and that's that's just
like a military term like observe Orient
decide effect and it's just the loop
with which that you can basically see
what's going on make a decision act on
it and then do that whole loop again
right because the faster you can pivot
and iterate the more responsive you are
as an entrepreneur the faster you can
take advantage of opportunities the
faster you can find out what failures
are then move on I want to talk about
this within the context of running a
team and employees and then also within
yourself and so from running your team
right one of the things that you know
once once you're moving out of you doing
things all the time there's how do I get
other people to do things and so that's
why I call this like creative week right
is that I one of the things one of my
biggest pet peeves is like yeah I can
get you that by end of week I'm like why
don't you just get it to me in an hour
because that's how long it takes and
then all of a sudden it's like oh it's
like well I have a meeting right then
it's like is it more important than this
no okay well then do it like if you
think about how you can run an
organization like that if you can get
things done end of day right rather than
end of week you were literally speeding
up the organization 7x think about that
and so you're thinking about deadlines
if you're thinking about expectations
you as the owner could set the x you set
the Cadence if people say hey can we do
this and then you're like cool let's
start right now you set the tone for how
the organization is going to move how
quickly it's going to orient how quickly
thoughts become reality and ultimately
how powerful the organization will
become because of the speed right and
speed isn't doing things fast it's
basically just not being distracted by
others it doesn't matter it's being able
to prioritize and most people a lot of
the times aren't doing something that's
high priority right A lot of times
they're just doing nothing if you can
speed up that Loop and Force and and put
apply pressure to your team to not do
things by end of week or even end of day
it's like it's 10 a.m can you get this
done by noon uh okay and then you can
have that Loop happen three times within
a day rather than it taking three weeks
right because you've set that Cadence
from the beginning and then things get
done faster so I've been reading some
really interesting books lately and I
referred them out to
um a handful of entrepreneur friends
that I have that are all doing five five
to Fifteen million kind of in that range
and what was amazing to me is that
every single one of them read the book
immediately sent me back their notes and
what they were going to do with it and
at like and basically we're asking
feedback on on the angle that they were
going to take with it what's fascinating
to me is that if you look at if you look
at lower level entrepreneurs they and
I'm not saying in a negative way I'm
just saying in terms of just objective
Revenue like just they haven't achieved
as much the delay between being able to
gain information and act is so much
longer and that's why they how where
they want to be it's kind of the same
degree of people who are like who pay
for our program and haven't gone through
the pool yet I'm like what do you do
right like what priority like what what
education do you have that is not
relevant to your business like you're
reading a motivational blog right now
when you have to translate that
motivation into a thought that you're
then going to quote test and then you
have to see how that test works and then
maybe it improves something rather than
just following the Playbook that has
already been tested and has already like
the the tree has been shook right and so
if you look at like Joey for example who
by by all definitions says James is the
is the number one gym within gym launch
right he had already finished everything
in Legacy by week eight his first eight
weeks he'd already implemented every
single system and Legacy and so it's not
like it's not like he has more hours in
the day right it's not like his business
is different it's just that his level of
efficacy and execution was so high
because it allowed himself to get
distracted by things and the moment he
has something he needs to execute it
creates this itch inside of him that he
cannot he can't move forward without
executing this so that the relief comes
and if you can start to Foster that type
of behavior in yourself and those
attitudes about execution you will grow
faster and you will become more powerful
as an entrepreneur right if you think
about your competition who would you
fear right the competitor who sees what
you're doing can immediately execute
Implement and improve on it at a faster
Loop than you can even understand what's
going on right and that's where speed of
first to Market and things like that
don't matter as much because if an X if
a competitor can execute an out ooda
Loop right can can speed that Loop up
faster they can iterate improve on it
faster than you can and then you have no
chance to catch up and so if you're
looking at your business look at it from
a context of speed of how long does it
take us to improve things how long from
understanding that our churn is high to
executing the five Horsemen how long did
that take we knew what the problem was
how long did it take for us to do and if
you can if you can if you can get real
with yourself about how many actual
hours it will take to do something and
then you look at your week and you think
okay what am I doing today that is more
important than this and where can I put
these two hours and start with the
moment that you make the decision and
then all of a sudden you'll be getting
things done that day that afternoon
rather than end of week end of month we
purposely delay these things because we
just procrastinate for no reason when
the the problem will not go away right
and so
that is why within Jamal speed is King
is one of the core tenants of the
business because you have to and the
tone has to start with you as the
entrepreneur like you have to apply that
pressure you have to say end of week why
like what are you doing today that's
more important than this right what are
you doing in the next two hours that's
more important than this tell me right
and a lot of times you'll get the answer
like well I guess I can do it now it's
like yeah then let's do it now let's get
it done right and that small change can
7x right if you even going from end of
week to end of day because 7x how
quickly your business grows because the
solutions that you need to implement to
solve the problems and break through the
bottlenecks happen today not in a week
not in a month and then the reaction to
the next thing that breaks the next
bottleneck in the business happens not
in a week not in a month but in a day
and then that's how quickly you can
pivot from where you are to where you
want to go because it's not one big
thing it's a million small turns that
will get you there a lot of people I
would say mistakenly think that the
number one resource is time
right everyone's like time is money time
is money time is money
and I would argue that that's not
necessarily true I would argue that
attention is money that is the golden
resource so the billionaire friend that
I have he's actually uh been helping me
on
um the new Endeavor that we are
launching to our gym Lords uh soon which
I think will change the industry anyways
he's been helping me with that stuff but
like here's an example on his phone his
phone does not ring unless you are
already a contact that has been
whitelisted his phone doesn't ring it's
he's impossible to reach the more
successful the more the the larger your
company grows the more you scale the
more you need to scale the only way to
scale you is because you do have a
finite amount of attention and so what
happens is you have to decrease all of
the other things in your life that drain
attention because you can have as much
time as you want but if you're not there
you're not potent you're not able then
you can't get anything done with that
time that you're supposedly allocating
which is why a lot of people end up in
this in between state of always
everywhere and at the same time nowhere
right and so they're they're everywhere
but they're not paying attention to
anything and that's and the reason that
it's difficult to focus is because
entrepreneurs the character trait that
made us into entrepreneurs is that we're
go-getters we're we're risk averse we're
creators we're innovators we're Builders
right we have all of those traits but
the difficulty is is that the thing that
gets you from zero to one is not the
thing that gets you from one to two
right and so one of the the reason that
you have to totally morph and why you
have to be growth oriented individual is
because you have to change your own
individual character traits in order to
progress as a business owner and so like
I said the things that got you here are
not the things that are going to get you
there the things that got you here which
is your own internal skills are not the
things that you need to pass on to other
people so the only way that you ever
able to grow your business at a certain
point is by growing other people right
and the only way you can do that is if
you have the attention and the bandwidth
in order to do so and that's why if you
look at a business owner and like the
more I obsess on looking at billionaires
and people who are doing better than we
are is I look at how quiet and how clean
they keep their space and I mean that
both in a literal sense that like their
surroundings their office their house
their homes their cell phone their
computers right there it's it's it's
quiet right everything like it's it's
pristine and when you talk to these
people there's a certain amount of of
Tranquility that's there and
and they just they just have very low
tolerance and it's not that they're
trying to be impatient with you or I'm
patient with the world it's just that
they understand that they have so like
they're they're operating at such a high
level that there's so many things that
are demanding of their time and
attention that they just like they can't
and so they have to forcibly remove
themselves from so many different
situations and I'm going to give you an
example so one of the people that I'm
I'm somewhat mentoring right they had
they had four businesses and this is
something that happens so many times it
lit like like you want you want a
hundred thousand dollar coaching this is
what happens in hundred thousand dollar
coaching sessions and I'm being honest
with you what happens is someone who's
coming in usually doing between one and
three million dollars a year
um can't get past a certain point right
and the reason they can't get past this
because they only have so much attention
and if it's spread between four or five
different kids that's when the gym owner
has four gyms and is making less money
than they did when they had one gym
because the amount of attention that
they can allocate to one facility has
gone down so much that with fixed costs
they basically are breaking even right
and so the same thing happens now that
entrepreneur is probably making one to
three million in gross revenue but not
taking anything home because they don't
have the intention to actually put onto
things and so in order to grow you need
to do less
in order to grow you need to do less and
that comes from both delegation and also
choosing what not to do the better you
get the better the opportunities that
you have to say no to imagine the level
of opportunities that we have now I'm
just being honest so imagine how many
things we could do or trying JV with or
do a partnership with or whatever
because of the distribution Network that
we have and the trust and the good will
that we have with the gym owners that we
have in our Network right a lot I get I
you know how many people cold message me
like I have an opportunity for you I'm
like really you have an opportunity for
me and so the better you get the better
your opportunities you have to say no to
which is why becoming a higher and
higher and higher level entrepreneur is
more and more difficult because it
requires discipline
it's not about doing more it's about
doing less because we innately want to
do more so doing more of your own
internal characteristic if that was what
it took to get to be more successful
then everyone would be more successful
because it would be something that does
not take effort because that is
something that we already do it's like
man I outwork anyone I've got all this
work ethic cool that gets you from zero
to one
it's not going to get you any further
than that so stop identifying with that
it was something that I used to identify
with I was like I'll I'll outwork anyone
or whatever like that was something that
I used to think about and it was a
character trade it was an identity thing
and the more you grow the more you
realize that your identity needs to be
fluid because what it needs to be is
exactly what it needs to be at that
given time of development because the
character traits that I'm going to have
to emphasize in a year are going to be
different than the ones that I have to
emphasize now the skills that you need
to learn like delegation leadership
those are things that are not the things
that take you in the beginning you have
to be independent you have to be
hustling you have to be grinding you
have to be willing to put in the work
because no one else will do it for you
especially if you have no Capital to
start which most of the people who are
on here are in that situation to reel
this back in the number one thing that
you have to be paying attention to is
where you are paying your attention
right like you spend attention that's
why they call it paying attention it's
because it is a resource and most people
don't pay attention to that right and so
one of the things that a lot of people
don't know about I mean this one's going
to go along
um
some of the things that a lot of people
don't know about me is that I for nine
months paid a coach to teach me one
thing which was to manage my attention
was to teach me how to think and so for
90 minutes every single day all I did
was talk about what I was thinking about
think about that
every day I paid attention to where my
attention was
and when I did that all of a sudden my
business blew up right and I realized
that I had toxic relationships I had
toxic relationships with parents I had
toxic relationships with friends or
pseudo friends things that I that were
taking my attention past things that I
had on my mind that I knew I had not
handled so those are called like open
Loops or open Cycles right so when you
have something that you like I haven't
resolved this then you need to handle
that and you'll get that attention back
because what happens is you have this
bowl this tiny little bowl of marbles
that each of those marbles is is a unit
of attention right if you had to measure
it and so you put little marbles of
attention on your childhood traumas you
put little marbles of attention on your
marriage you put little uh marbles of
attention on your health you put little
marvelous attention on your spirituality
and then massive marbles of attention on
your business but the thing is is that
sometimes you need to quiet and collect
all of these other little marbles so
that you have more potency more
potential energy more potential units of
attention to spend on on the one thing
that you're trying to grow which in this
case would be your business and what's
interesting is that what happens is that
things that were perceived as difficult
become really easy and I don't know if
you've ever had this happen but like if
you were in college or you were in high
school and you were like man I can't
solve this problem this math problem and
you were exhausted then you go to bed
then you wake up the next morning and
then all of a sudden it seems really
easy or you're like I don't know why I
didn't see that before because attention
gives you the ability to see
right like if you're if you think about
wisdom right wisdom is an ability to see
what other people cannot see right two
people are presenting the same situation
the wiser person sees things that the
other person does it and how can you see
better you see better if you have more
ability to see which comes from your
most valuable resource attention how
much horsepower do you have and so look
at the things that you have in your in
your life right now like if I see
someone who has a messy relationship
life who's got a messy love life who
goes out every weekend and gets trashed
right like I can tell you billionaires
don't do that that like the whole Tony
Stark like vision of the entrepreneur is
a farce it's not true don't believe that
every single billionaire every single
high-level entrepreneur is quiet
unbelievably quiet they keep themselves
completely isolated they have a bubble
around them of of layers of protection
they're like like for me it's it's me
and then there's Layla and then we have
our CEO and then we have our executive
assistant team because we have a team of
EAS at this point we have four
um who work the next level there's no
one who has direct access to me
including our employees no one does and
that's because it's it would disserve
you you guys our gym owners if everyone
had access to me the reason that I don't
respond to Facebook messages is not
because I don't want to it's because I
literally can't and if I did I would be
disturbing everyone because then my
attention would be split because someone
can't generate leads in their mind or
whatever you know what I mean like
because these little things these little
things that are perceived as huge issues
to you in that moment because you have a
little bit of attention you you have so
little left that everything seems like
an explosion but when you have lots of
capacity City big problem seems small
and small problems seem big and it
sounds reverse because what you do is
you start seeing that all of these
things are attention drains and you just
say I don't want to play anymore
and you stop playing
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Grant Cardone
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there if you've got a
thousand dollars I would like just keep
investing yourself until you got another
thousand and then invest in yourself you
should start making money faster you
know there's things I bought that I
didn't get a return on right away but I
didn't quit investing in a course or a
workshop